all right if we all love the last word
with Laura Cognito Andy boxes Friday
night campfire what is going on sir do
we have like never guess I guess a
returning guests an awesome gentleman
here who lives in the world of Max
triumphs score always aspiring to be top
in the destiny world there's not too
much left I think you might have one or
two things that you saw you were working
on but we'll cover that here in a sec
but yeah it's been an interesting week
lots of stuff to talk about lots of
controversial topics so yeah it's
definitely gonna be an interesting one
let's introduce to me welcome to the
last word episode number 104 it's
another glorious Friday we back in front
of the campfire for some more ludus
shooter discussion I'm extremely excited
about special guest so we gonna get
right into it
I want to introduce the Lord whom is an
absolute pleasure to stop by the destiny
can fire for some informative discussion
known as this law one of our most
passionate hard core members of the
community but by earning every Guardian
games triumph has absolutely earned the
right to take a break from season other
worthy introducing our favorite Guardian
from clan concern and we'll have the
best IT guys in the game fellow friend
to fire team chat fellow warlock main
and the most elite Xbox controller user
on PC that's right that's right
live from California and making his
return into the realm of the last word
mommy Lord teasing teddy how we do
exactly that intros even better the last
one I don't know I'm doing all right
do you know hanging in there yeah
hopefully you guys are doing the same
and thank you again for having me this
is this is always fun to you know talk
about something we're very passionate
about so absolute pleasure to have you
brother good to have you back there got
a lot to talk about a lot to catch up my
going on in the world man it was but
otherwise a net like have you been on
playing destiny again I know you we
talked offline you took a break a little
bar I think you took a break around us a
top I took a break so I'll be how how's
that going with destiny in particular I
the season has been obviously the
lackluster
to say the least
I've been playing very on and off the
last month I got really busy so I I kind
of haven't been playing as much as I
wanted to but I still would just jump on
to do whatever was relevant at the time
so when Almighty became available for
the title and fell in the fell interest
quest became sort of available and then
not available and then available again
and so you know I just get on when I
need to and now this weekend I'm
actually going to knock out conker I'll
probably do it after this broadcast as
is my goal to these Tanakh that I only
have the to two more left probabilities
as I see I watched really working on it
yeah I watched I was kognito and scare
oh no I'm not cutting a pyro and scarole
both working on who was the first one
bird hold they worked on that one and
then it's all up in the rotation so you
can pick any of the ones you need to
work on and then I watched some tree of
probabilities hours just hours working
on that one so it's just the dicey room
so I just wanted to ask you actually
since you're talking about conquer and
stuff I know you I know why you do it
you're going for the title you're going
for the completionist for sure is that
where you continue to want to see
content go I'm watching those guys just
like hide in little corners and do these
certain things like I watched Exodus
crash same thing I saw some people just
stand on a box strat like type thing so
is that where you would like to see
content to go or is it just to a point
of like it's hard just to be mean like I
wondered what your thoughts on those
have been so far cuz I really haven't no
VIN but looking at like 12 modifiers
seems daunting but if you're just
apparently good to go you seem to knock
him out so I was curious in general I I
don't necessarily like the Grandmaster
nightfalls I see what they were going
for and I think the thing that kind of
so the part I are really salty about was
when they announced contests being
enabled for it because I had prepped
very heavily at the beginning of the
season during season 9 for all this I
stacked like a lot of bounties and then
when and then we were playing super hard
mean butch clan mates basically go as
high as we possibly could in order to
you know have as much advantage as
possible when they announced contest and
that put a really big damper on like the
six weeks of effort we had to put
but then I came out and we started
playing them and they weren't that bad
like yeah you got a you got a play a
certain way but I I played d1 and that's
what we did in d1 like you know just sat
in a corner somewhere and you yeah it's
just funny I see them try and get away
from that now it's like all right so
we're gonna sit here with these two
izanagi's in this crib thing or
everybody seems to need area on ass foul
which is kind of sucks for the people
who miss shadow keep because that yeah
that's a brutal one right now if you
don't have that gun that's pretty hard
on some of these ever yeah but it's I I
wouldn't say they're unfair I I think
they actually did quite a good job of
balancing the content like they aren't
difficult but they're not like like I
feel like some of the other things
they've done it's like the contents very
unfair and you just you have to play
this like very specific way that being
said for all the grandmasters you do
have to play a specific way and have
your loadouts very optimized but once
you understand what you're going up
against it's actually not that bad do I
like the title no I won't put the title
on I do like the concept of that title
as well as flawless in the same boat
where they will be available every
season but the requirements will shift
or change depending on what for Congress
the strikes and then for trials they
haven't exactly said what will what will
change but I like that idea because at
least sit it gives other players who
maybe aren't as hardcore dedicated to
chase after the fact but it's mainly
just a check mark for me at this point
it's like it's the last title I don't
have i I've I've started this weird
tradition that I regret doing
mackynzie's of opulence where at the end
of every season I have to get all the
triumphs that were like hey get back
[ __ ] score which I currently do have I
just don't have the title because it's
they're all worth zero so it's that bugs
the hell out of me
yeah but yeah yeah well that's another
thing I'm torn on but I won't get into
that that's that's that's just like a
weird nitpick thing as far as like I
said I know you did that I'll be I gave
her I sorted the Guardian games when I
was just like god bless his soul because
this
you brought at that bow it was just so
many bunnies and they like I looked at
you an 11 411 on that one yeah I knocked
it out of the first three days okay I
did it much longer I was like I did it
but damn three days no I yeah I wanted
to get a sister's to get three nope you
were just like as soon as I just bull
type thing I after day two I basically
did the math and was like okay I have to
do it on all three characters and I have
to hope that day three the other medals
that hadn't popped up at that point pop
up and they did thankfully they were all
like a cycle and so I just I played a
lot in three days a disgusting amount of
time and then I put the game down I was
like I'm not touching this game anymore
that being said I like heir-apparent a
lot I think the guys mind it's very
unique very destiny and I was kind of
glad that I got it like a day before
everyone else got it because going to
crucible and hitting people that was
pretty funny you guys that terrorized me
that's what you glad you said that
that's what motivated me to get it
because I saw obviously I saw the
initial reviews and most people were
looking at it from a PvE perspective I'm
not okay it's cool chaingun blah blah
blah but literally I forgot I'm gonna
say I was playing comp and it was all
you know survival for before like you
know no lives on either side you know
it's it's down to them have the opposing
team having to and it was just me but
I've got my Nova walk charge and I'm
ready to come around the corner so there
I guess one of the guys was over there
by heavy but I don't care it doesn't
matter go nowhere about just you know
blink and whatever there so he shoots I
blink poof one guys and the other one
doesn't dad he's got this blue aura
around him I'm like what is going on so
I'm like alright
poof again and he stands there tanks it
and shoots me and I'm like yo that's and
it says heir-apparent
I like no I gotta get this guy
did it prove it I was like I was I could
not have anybody else without this good
because that is a powerful ability
especially a BBB the show it's it's a
fun gun I think I think if anything to
be said about guarding games that was
kind of the highlight of it yes it was
it was it's a it's a very destiny gun
and all yeah that one was a nice
addition for sure mm-hm well it's been
an interesting week into and more than a
couple weeks now actually so we do have
access to our shotgun of choice which
will be the shotgun that you'll probably
see in PvP for approximately nine months
and three weeks and Counting I would
imagine
çb great thank you for tuning in
previous guests listen maybe so we have
access to that but yeah we've got a
little bit of a story since between last
word podcasts last last word we weren't
there yet we were like counting down and
then it happened over the weekend and
all this stuff so by the time we got
here it's been interesting so I wanted
to ask kognito first and then you as
well as all of the like events of the
felwinter's like West transpired just
kind of what was your journey through it
thoughts and everything about itself
Judy oh yeah it's not a fun story
because um like I said I was very very
but very upset with let's just say it up
and they're not happy um like Teddy said
you know heir apparent was literally the
only reason why I pushed through
Guardian games alright we all knew the
family - Quest was coming so I'm like
alright everybody know that that is true
that is true but those didn't know you
know so we like alright cool and like I
said you know last word the last last
word um I started out and you know I saw
the public event require I mean I went
to enterbrain and you go to see the
public event requirement I'm like okay
cool let me do my first cell tower and
then I saw no percent I mean I saw one
percent but I saw nothing really elevate
on the bar and I said oh no I was like
so this is of a community focused thing
and I'm just like that much
I care about ready for this so I I
promptly said I'm jumping on I'll being
on strike and I'm gonna let the
community do this because I did what
about Thomas so I'm sitting there
watching from the outside shout to say
this to shout out to you you guys always
keeping me abreast what was going on
then we had the first snafu obviously
you know with the bunker and stuff like
that and I'm like no the quest is not
blocked you know so as that went on I'm
okay cooled and I think it was I'm gonna
say a Sunday that is us at least Sunday
that happened and eleven o'clock by the
time shows right pretty close to the end
of the evening right so there was I
heard it was very I was happy that they
were able to get in front of that
obviously we aren't about to fix it all
a lot of stuff and then at that point
I'm like okay I'll get back in so I'm
about to embark on it obviously you have
stories because you I'm something half
the gun already right you've went there
yeah yeah all you guys went through it I
mean I will say this you know as far as
the the gun itself and and the quest as
a whole from a lore perspective I'm
hearing good things but again my concern
is when a lot of this content is
publicly event community-based what it
is shown is if there is any problem
right
you have now halted the storyline you
have halted the advancement of the game
until you can get this is all that's why
these question in my opinion a poor and
a lot of the Destiny community is very
upset you know and not happy with it but
I want to bring it back to you guys you
guys have it you guys have the gun
overall you know I bring it back to you
tight like what's your experience of the
whole thing do you feel it was worth it
now that you have it like give me that
your whole breakdown on the whole film
the lie
so does we I think the question itself
was was good - the two issues so I'll
bring I'll break out break it down I was
really busy the week that it started so
I was not planning on participating in
the surf towers even if I did enjoy the
surf towers i would still not have done
it I really don't like the surf towers I
made that clear
I I think there's some of the most
poorly designed like thing I mean by
everyone a bunch of super talent and I
respect all of them but like you know
serve towers suck and then when we add
it
when when they added when they changed
the way they worked for the Almighty
title basically were you have to at the
same time I think that was like that was
like the nail in the coffin for them
yeah oh yeah basically and so so the
quest came out and I already known the
quest steps because was data mined
pretty early on in the season and I I I
tend to be very selective on what
spoilers I look up yeah because I want I
want to plan around like if a quest
later in the season is gonna take a lot
of time I want to be able to plan my
work schedule around that and be able to
like you know do that so I looked at him
gen extents understand what's going on
and I saw the first step was going to be
community event and my first reaction
was this is just like another form of
time gating like there's nothing there's
no difference between time getting the
quests and making the community do
something other than like there's an
active level of participation but the
thing you're making them participate in
is not liked by many people so it was
this kind of weird thing and then
obviously was bugged or I guess they
assumed this number would be like that's
Matt remember is nut still I
I think they intended my theory I have
nothing to back this up my theory is
that they intended for that to last the
whole season and then at some point like
during the season we were supposed to
finish it but for whatever reason that
didn't happen yeah so anyway the
community got it and I had happen to
have like a small break that night when
it when I got completed so Cardle jump
on I'll also go into the quest you know
I got my Shoji's checkpoints started
going to do my shotgun wah and I did it
and then my friends were a little bit
ahead of me and so I was I was
definitely the discord and I can't pack
up there they're all kind of like
memeing and making fun of stuff knows
what's going on and they're like they're
like well the quests bugged and they
just tweeted it out and like well I'm
trying this came off when the exit I'll
come back to it and so yesterday when I
got fixed I I jumped down quickly before
my work stuff and I grabbed it and I do
really like the story aspect of it I've
always liked spell winter again a
warlock figure in the more so yeah
and second sure it's a walk stand out
yeah so I like the story and I I had
watched videos of the area that you go
to people glitching into it but I think
it was cool to kind of see it with like
the narrative be and like and what was
going on so I understand what they were
going for and I appreciate that they
they fixed it quickly and they were they
were pretty humble about it yes but it
kind of it really like sucked that it
happened at the very end of the season
and it happened after guardian games and
it happened during this season's
particularly though it wasn't that good
mm-hm and I don't know just it it just
seems in a weird place right now and
we'll get to that in a soon but like
it's it's just like this like tiny drop
that it just made it so much worse than
it actually was
but yeah what do you what do you
thinking I need you map diagonally
abreast I've been you know jumping
occasionally do a few public events I
there was one point I was like hey I'll
go to the moon
and I saw people like kind of standing
around and people are like doing general
chat and stuff trying about it was like
hey actually trying to get a group
together be like hey we got like two
people here that need the all my name
like alright I tripped into a group
who's actually trying to be sad they're
like two runs had it done for whatever
random people were there so I was like
I've done these off and on throughout
the season but as you said you're like
you get done with Guardian games the
ultimate bounty of specific crazy bounty
Ryan's of all time and you're like hey
you need to do this with one hand tied
behind your back throwing your shield at
least 20 yards across the field off one
bank shot okay so that you're like
alright we made it through all the
Guardian games Titans are over there
with their little statue that's like
just as tall as a guardian no bigger
yeah why is the statue so small but
anyway okay it is actually like the size
of a guardian I walked my guy up to it
but yeah you would I don't know if you
would just picture it like you know
picture like Justice League how tall is
the Superman statue I'm like that's like
15 feet tall it's pretty damn big like
how I expected yeah it's like just the
size of a guardian walking around the
tower I'm like just what were they
planning for future years to stack up
next to each other I don't know but yeah
we make the row that and then like it
kicks off and we're like alright 9
million and I was just like holy
and then what I what I was doing at
first is I was tracking to see like okay
so we've done this meted to this mini
and I started tracking by like hours so
I started tracking like for 21 p.m. and
I was like okay so about 5:21 after an
update us okay we did this mini I was
like if we stay at this pace big giant
if if people don't get tired of this
thing it's gonna take this long to do a
DZ and that was like seven days and I'm
like we have four weeks left in the
season technically it could be done if
they start falling off next day it got a
little bit slower like by the time I got
to about the third day of tracking just
the time of this thing which is probably
when the patch came that it was gonna be
changed I was like European dead zones
gonna take like two weeks and we don't
have that much time I was like it ain't
gonna happen it was gonna be like 14
days or 250 I was like that's not right
it's not gonna happen
no and then magically and then yeah it's
like all of a sudden they're like hey
that during the week it's 5x and the
weekend it's 10x I was like how do you
wit it's like again as as Teddy said
it's like either it was meant to be like
hey we start this at the beginning of
the season it tracks all season long
which if they did that and that set that
expectation that would probably be fair
and be like hey every softie and you'd
be like hey I'm on let me go throw
another you know public event in the
pile because there's 9 million of them
and you have 12 weeks to do it we've
been doing these that we we worked for
our bits which apparently have no other
use which seems to be really sad because
they're going away at the end of the
season like I've got 7,000 bits I'm like
really nothing to spit them on so we we
already grinded enough for all three and
we've been doing these things that
weekly bounties and then we're like 9
million and then when you do that math
you're something the the math in this
season as well as many other things has
been a little skewed either the Titan
the hunter waiting math and Guardian
games and the 9 million public events
the waiting has been off but it's like
it got to that point I'm like ok so if
it I was just like all right so they
bumped it up to 5x and it was like all
right he's actually tracking I could see
and then you see raid secrets put
together the spreadsheet that's tracking
like the estimated finish time did you
tag me in that one actually I did yeah
it's like so I started watching that one
and then they started working on the
moon and it was starting to climb a
little faster over the weekend because
10x got going I was like okay this
thing's moving it was like and then when
they were getting ready to finish the
moon was like ok it's like 24 hours
later they're probably gonna finish IO
and
I kept checking it and the estimated
time just started walking back and I'm
like at some point I figured that would
slow down nah it just sped up because it
was like noon and this was like Pacific
time 10/8 4:00 in the morning like back
to like midnight I'm like Jesus is gonna
be done in like 90 minutes you're like
okay so the community is coming together
behind this thing final push everybody's
on streaming now mmm and you just watch
Twitter be like hey we're on we're gonna
go for this final push be it glad dad Oh
cactus all these people about 30 minutes
later glad dad asked a coke going to bed
sorry kognito should not have had
anything as a mouth at that point so we
didn't spit it all over his camera
you're like yes I got my shotgun kills
you did sir Oh Chi my brother actually
got on which was like hey we're sitting
there in the Leviathan just trade kills
chatting for a little bit because his
birthday was in like 30 minutes from
that point shout out to my brother
people and then all of a sudden we're
going through and like you go down in
the bunker like cool the next step after
the kills you get back out now I'm like
sitting there and at first I'm kind of
with you because I was a little behind
and I was like yeah is there a puzzle is
there something about Phil went right
don't remember I need to go look
somewhere on the moon but there's no
marker and then I'm like is it a puzzle
and then finally like everybody starting
to say its bugged and then finally the
official tweet came out from DG and
everybody's just like shutting it down
it's just like yeah and it just took the
giant wind at let me the whole community
to come together it's like the it's like
the corridors of time puzzle being there
and then you going through 29 of the 30
rooms and the 29th one is like like you
you keep getting an error code or
something it gets at that point or
something like that would be the only
way I can kind of relate it to anything
to get that close and then it just be
like nope and especially when they said
hey they're looking into it we've got an
idea and they said hey they've got to go
through testing and certification I
thought was gonna be like another week
so they got to it faster than I thought
they would yeah I mean they pushed it
slowly as honestly when I expected like
an easy week because I mean council
certifications can take a little while
they're not gonna be fixed so they
pushed patches out and it was when I
finally got to finish it
on was it
Thursday yesterday yeah it's been a
weird week days are still weird when I
finally got to finish it like going
through the little bit of lore that we
got and then I went to go get 200 kills
you've got the whole lore book which I
do like that
question is that is the lore worthy
because I need and I need to know I need
to II you know I age approval which I
thought was worthy I thought yeah I
thought the story behind
go ahead Teddy I just watched the bike
video actually before we started
recording and he the point yeah I shot
survived he did a whole forty minute
video on the entire lore book and it was
pretty good actually I enjoyed it I
wouldn't got the kills for the shotgun
or the second floor as well because
unfortunately there's triumph score tied
to it
so but I liked it it was and if opens
some gaps from what we previously known
about it was good okay good good good
that's why I wanted to make sure I just
I mean we understand the issue but I had
to ask that specific part if the law was
deaf if they if they if they nailed it
I'm very curious yeah I feel like like
just pay attention to the story like
when you go to play that quest turn off
all distractions like pay attention to
the story little voiceovers and
everything turn that up and just enjoy
it because honestly like it was it was
interesting because I went through that
and then people in my chat we're
literally discussing like well hey this
side of the opinion of what you know
said person did I'm trying to be very
vague since you haven't actually seen
today there's like hey this person did
these things we can't you know not you
know we can't forget about those and
this person's like well it has been this
long since all this has happened you
know mulling it all over for so long
maybe there's change in there and that
was what was going on working in my chat
and I was just like so it's like just
the fact that chat was actually talking
about it was kind of going okay alright
but yeah it's like it has I liked the
idea behind that but again this is one
of those weird things to where in theory
this is cool I like the I like also the
way it was delivered for the non
spoilery you you'll know exactly what
game I'm picturing they did story
delivery like this when you see at you
and Teddy I don't know if you played it
is a ax it's another type of game like
this
I'm trying not to spoil it I don't like
your dancing I like you I like you okay
if you want me to just tell them how
it's delivered lake yeah you could tell
them how to them
okay picture division story I've done
the mission I just I don't know what
you're referencing exactly oh he snuck
in the in the deceiver chamber a nice
ball okay of course just every soft in
one little blip I was gonna say picture
division story delivery mm okay ya know
something kind of like that okay and
that's what I've either I've been
playing through neo2 which unlike two
chapters away from finishing crazy good
game so far I'm kicking my butt by the
way but they do like animated kind of
storyboards like not crazy high fidelity
but picture just like kind of an artist
a brief drawing and like there's art in
there but it's like it's not fully
rendered cutscenes and it's like okay
like I want it like if they do something
like that or more stuff like this either
way and again this fits because of who's
telling the story of why it's presented
this way mmm
but story like engaging in story in game
like going to read the Lord book in the
game I'm just gonna sit there hey let me
pull up my Lord tab and sit in the tower
and be like book one no no book to
scroll no verse is the way it's
delivered in this one I like that a lot
more so more of this I would love to see
and especially as it's being tied like
hey this is why you get this gun and
then there's the Lord look afterwards
all that stuff's very cool but again how
in the hell does that tie in to the
Almighty yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
valid continue this it's more of I think
it's more about the Rasputin story more
than just appeal - in himself yeah him
and him in the other character
you're the one who has a podcast on
Friday and you didn't take this time to
get the gun
what you mean I didn't take this time to
get the girls it takes like five minutes
if you have the killers guns and ammo on
strike since our public event
foolishness I'm not doing that until
they resolve that and then I get that
listen you gotta stand up for something
sometimes that was not acceptable
content don't get mad it because I chose
to say that word I'm just saying that so
any problem during that proverb I said
you know what I'm gonna take some time
to take knock out some backlog I like
three games finish like I like Final
Fantasy seven finish I'm always through
go gears tactics I got bored of combat
look I got very productive so I'll be
here this week but it's like it is cool
to give back story I'm just curious how
this ties in to the rest of the season
we have the almighty government we had
the moment when you know Cevallos
talking RS butan kind of comes to like a
peace accord basically between those two
it's like okay we're actually gonna work
together and that was how many weeks ago
six weeks ago that that knows maybe not
that far it's been a long time that
that's happened and there's still this
giant ship hurtling towards Earth which
granted the way it travels through space
it could appear technically in the
horizon on the last day before it
actually gets to be visible not gonna
happen that way I'm still just like I
want the season to kind of finish I'm at
that one yeah yeah yeah it's like it's
just like hey all my T's coming pyramid
ships are gonna do something which that
math is either I wanted to ask you guys
put a paint on the pyramid ships want to
come back to that a minute but all the
stuffs like culminating and I'm just
like I'm just like dying to grab the
next page of the book and pull it over
just to see what the hell happens
because right now I'm just like as soon
as I got the shotgun on Tuesday or
Thursday I was just like mmm back now
what literally my chains like back to
the oh I guess like it was those bikes
and I was so that's been it's been a
very weird journey all season long and
then to culminate in a huh and then like
emotional hide to like a cliff falling
off into an oblivion hole is like it's
been quite a roller coaster so and it's
a game it's not that big of a deal but
in within the game yeah it's been a
roller coaster
mm-hm sorry that was a lot of talking
no you're good you're good I'm listen
it's just it's just we got a quality
it's easier to wear these just unworthy
it just as a whole as a content you know
saying in comparison to other content
this is probably been the lowest I've
seen you know I'm saying a lot
this is below curse of Osiris level and
look we love them we love them together
is just one of those times you know I'm
saying that the content didn't hit and a
lot of the ideas didn't hit and um like
I'm with Yui I'm so ready to see what's
the next connective tissue from this
almighty thing to what are we gonna do
next
and we know out like you said the pins
on the wall Doritos are inbound we got
it
we know about that but it's just like
how quickly do we do Doritos you know
Dewey today do they send an emissary is
it you know because we we know
September's gonna be crazy Luke told us
that right Luke said you are not ready
for what's about to happen in September
but it's just the cure by curiosity from
a narrative beat man what is going to
happen so that's why I need this thing
to be over so I'm going along and for us
that have completed the quest when it
comes to when it comes to when it comes
to next season do you think it's related
to basically the bait in this quest what
do you all I can't ask that cuz I would
elaborate I'm not exactly sure question
is what I mean for what said character
what caused said character's demise the
unnamed character do you think that is
gonna have any relation to okay no you
don't think that's going to be next I I
think this story is portal
self-contained and they they the
Rasputin part of it maybe because it's
meant to show us without spoiling it I'm
like trying really hard
the rest part of it is meant to show us
a different side of respect and
understand Rasputin's history and I
think that will be relevant when the
actual other characters aspect of it is
just there to satisfy just explain that
characters journey yeah yeah basically
and explain some previous mishaps in the
war or not mishaps but I guess missed
aspects yeah when it comes to season and
11 season of the reacted I don't want to
know what the hell is gonna happen like
we're doing away I know the trailer is
probably gonna drop on June 3rd like the
winds-day before it drops and stuff same
the way that they did last time but I
was just over here Diane cuz again it's
like a log on for a Tuesday and be like
this Tuesday was literally like well we
know the quest is bugged there is no
iron banner back to me like it's been
that's these last three weeks this says
like and more and I'm like okay we got
the quest we did that but again I just
want to know how this stuff wraps up
because at some point they can't tell us
about the next season till we finish up
the almighty this almighty might lead
into something else so I'm just like on
the edge of my seat
to know what's next but that's odd
there's nothing in game for me to do I'm
literally just waiting to see how the
story ends so here's a question around
this time last year we got the outbreak
prime quest it's our and then in August
of 2018 we got whispers a little bit
later but well so on the same time and
do you think we have that at the end of
this season or are they just not gonna I
think this was that you think so yeah I
don't think there's I guess pretty
lackluster in comparison for sure no
argument that this is lackluster they
had more backing during both of those
two times to be able to have teams
divided off into making requests and
just one with the way it was delivered
between public events and the NISS and
then just the the general way the lore
is explained and stuff like that I think
that's that's what they have time for
right now I mean you have you know
senior artists like you know nine hydras
talking out there about like the the
room that they built in the end just
kind of look of it in the cool and it's
like it's sick but it's like they built
I don't know if there's another one of
those out there I don't see how many how
many weeks we have left what what is our
time frame two and a half
two and a half and as of right now
there's no specific roadmap calendar
item since Guardian guardian games was
it guardian games said and more that was
all yeah I I agree I don't I don't think
there's enough time for anything of that
magnitude like what you're saying Ted as
far as like an outbreak or you know
whisper kind of thing it would be a
little too close to the end but I I will
see shout out to UM was a crystal and in
a chat there's a possibility of some
minor maybe lower beat or did you know
like a again another connective tissue
beat which is like um for example that
when we finished um what you call it and
Osiris goes up to Rasputin and we had
that cutscene when you long I think we
may get like something similar to that
one a reset well you know coming in
because they got they have to connect
this thing I mean we do know obviously
only at mom oh my he's coming that
probably might be it right the almighty
comes you know when I would it's looming
you know they're kind of thing I know in
satellites later or strange me they're
not that many but still be okay yeah
there's a scene in the trailer for this
season at the very beginning when we got
when a season where a warlock wearing
Phil earnest home a bunch of NPCs are
standing by a core and looking up
looking off kind of like covering their
hands or faces I mean with their hands
yeah
and that hasn't happened I mean I could
that could have just been them just
recording like a thing in game because
it looked like it was an engine and was
in a cutscene mmm-hmm
well yeah I'm kind of with you I hope
there is some kind of like cutscene or
connective thing because it was a little
lackluster to see Osiris go talk to
Rasputin and then though Cyrus has not
been part of the season he just kind of
vanished he's like we're saying do you
think Rasputin and Osiris system was
discussion was about what we just
learned
do you think that's what he said he is
like do you think that's linked uh I
yeah yeah I could see that okay
I was I was somebody said that it I
don't know but at least in my head it
was like I could see that as to why he
was
the way he was right because yeah it
depends on the debate of where you stand
after you get done seeing this Lord so
right yeah I think that would make sense
again I'm Trevor Lee right now to spoil
this by launching this later on you guys
can give Cognito hell next week we the
store implication is meant to show us a
side of Rasputin yes and I think Osiris
has found out the ugly part of that
story and that's why he says that but
from us as the outside perspective
viewing it it's meant to show us a
deeper side and like a better side and
that's like probably Sega's I can make
it they don't actually you guys give me
so much time so I could get back just is
like something expectation the mission
is not very long it's it's like five ish
minutes it's a good dialogue so it kind
of a cigar describing kind of reminds me
and correct me if I'm wrong if Cevallos
conversation with Rasputin and as to
motivations and stuff obviously it's
more than that but I'm just saying like
context on why maybe he does the things
he does obviously we know about Ted
character in it most people know already
but you know say I want to I'm very
curious about that so um yeah I mean
we'll see
I mean you now have to text me when you
get this gun only 30 minutes after the
podcast ends either way you have to text
me I definitely did it last boy because
we didn't talk about this I gotta ask
both of you um the gun fell which is
like how are you guys feeling about it
you guys put it in the water it'll be
popular so I'm probably gonna sing okay
yeah Teddy so I have a god rolled my
menders that I'm very attached to that I
grinded a lot for yes and everything
that a lot and they're not the same rule
though they're similar because my
vendors can't get opening shot alice is
the curated role yes so I kind of mess
with both of them a little bit I did and
I got on put a lot of PvP so I'm not I
don't think I'm the right person to ask
for this but I think that winters is
slightly more consistent and it can have
the potential for like very deep one-hit
kills but it still suffers from the
shotgun or
gee mm-hmm however the one advantage
that it does have is that it's a later
seasoned gun which means when mine
vendors gets retired mm-hmm this gun
Walter Miller this is the new yeah and
this is a quest item though they did say
that this quest does go away at the end
of the season so if you don't get it in
the next week's I ready yeah you got
real to get it
that being said from preliminary videos
that I've watched and read a post it
seems like a god world astral horizon is
actually theater okay I don't have one
of those unfortunately so I can test it
myself but I also kind of don't care if
it would be perfectly honest yes I just
don't play enough yeah what do you think
about this it did you use it have you
like that I'm always like I'm okay at
PvP and I even tried it out on the
stream just a joke as I was like I got
it all right let's go play PvP I was
like I am so out of practice with
shotguns it's not funny but just
listening to different people talk about
it by the time it came out I think
especially you follow this video he did
some really deep testing on it and stuff
like that was what's there what'd he say
uh I mean the range for him on his foot
on his mind benders consistency for him
is like seven and a half meters not
quite and this one can consistently kill
at eight so it can out range it and you
can just pick opening shot and I think
the difference is as you said this is
Susanville worthy it's gonna be
available for another year so nine more
months everybody who's playing right now
can get this thing at this point so
those who are currently playing right
now are gonna potentially basically be
guaranteed to have a very very good
shotgun and be able to avoid set grind
which we'll get into more of a
discussion later they don't have to go
spin three you know three we know three
months in you know the Mindbenders grind
and just be like hey I've gone through
this strike ten times a day I haven't
even got one to drop yet versus go
through the quest
everybody does it I have a direct path I
get my thousand kills and I get a gun
that is very very very viable and next
to comparable if not equal to some of
the top guns that you can get there
maybe smidgen like and if the trials can
out match it barely that actually
probably is where it should be if you
can't get the right role but be like
time to get one versus the other
now like this is gonna be just pop
as can be this popular okay no no I'm
glad you guys broke it down that way I'm
very curious I was one of the very
unlucky ones I tried to grind and never
die to Mindbenders to try out you know
also be being a PvP guy I'm very excited
because you know I want to use you know
sycophancy 600 so good right now so I
want to use suros regime and something
in energy what I would so I can give up
my lord of wolves I happened to use that
all the time you know so um yeah I'm
excited then the the the vorpal aspect
has me intrigued because as a trials
player I'm thinking you know maybe Derby
and it's you have the selectable perks
during like later rounds when everyone's
got their super switch in a vocal in you
know it's kind of easy you know they at
that point during the later round so I'm
curious man I'm excited for hits solar
and I like the aesthetic of it so I will
be getting that done so he can get off
my back on the pocket
so quick follow-up question to that so
Bungie has this track record of when
they give us a very powerful gun yeah
they've curated that they end up nerfing
that archetype yeah slate like very
closely after the fact we go to speak
about that because it was alluded to in
the club yeah and so giving everyone a
God rode shotgun to me it's like we're
gonna nerf shotguns pretty soon enjoy
have it yep you you're so it's literally
bungees way I'm always said of like okay
we recognize that issue have your fun
hard light from zhurba for a from you
know to Bob's
I'm telling you us so onto something
like yeah I completely agree yeah for
them to give you that it's something's
coming so yeah that's even saying it's
like when I played the couple I played
two matches and they said and granted it
was right when the gun came out so I'm
sure it's skewed but they said like 9
out of 12 people are using this thing oh
yeah actually while we're doing this I
can go look up trials report because it
is the report said he says saw Rosenfeld
woods is gonna be the new meta he bets
oh man yeah I'm thinking it you know the
worst is 275 thousand kills revoke hers
number two at one hundred eighty two
thousand kills it's slick top
I don't even know how to describe that
when it's like that it's was really bad
spawns yeah I can play that at a it's
the one that is inside like they're like
heavy is on that like weird little
middle like to hallway area now heavy
it's like kind of on this side you've
got just gonna be the ecstatic that it
will help its on earth in the heed easy
my grace the house yep and then like
yellowish warehouse and sees in the
yellowish warehouse yeah under you can
split both ways yeah yes yes yes yeah
you'll have some close range definitely
people and as close range business or
yeah yeah oh it's gonna be spooky
Mindbenders is at 51 k felwinter's is a
275 it's only been out for how long
I came out Thursday yeah I mean trials
is today so yeah Jesus
yeah that's forgot so besides the fact
that we got the quest we also got a
table got a couple different things of
discussion and I will honestly say and
I've actually be curious on chat when
you guys read this just first time
through I was like kind of watching a TV
show in the background came up I was
like oh this actually came out a little
earlier than usually like 45 minutes
earlier usually it's later but and I was
reading through it the first time I read
through it I'm like what did I just read
yeah it wasn't the clearest thing in the
world when it comes to the decryption
look in grams and like that whole world
blue pool thing when they're like hey
yeah we just talked about the world loop
pool and I'm like wait which things come
where and if I've had a red and most so
it's clarified one of my questions which
helped yeah so obviously the lie was the
big issue this week but then they were
gonna talk about the future they're
gonna talk about more rewards going into
next season and decrypting the future is
and this is gonna tie into sunsetting
sisters can be one big-ass discussion
sorry in advance so today they said
we're going to talk about some changes
that are coming to season 11 to the way
the world loop pool works because the
world loop pole serves as a baseline of
legendary gear that can be earned across
different activities we want to update
and refresh it seasonally with meta
relevant weapons some of which were
previously exclusive to
specific activities like gambit or
crucible this shared loophole can be
unwieldy if you're looking for a
specific role of a specific weapon a
pool too large can make it statistically
challenging to find much less with the
role you want I think we can all agree
that's 100% true because people like hey
I want to go for what does that little
sidearm the last hope
last hope feeding frenzy yeah multi kill
clip I still don't have that role yeah I
want frenzy but not that I want to scare
oh go through what was the lake half a
million fractal I'm trying to get one of
those and he ended up getting one there
Wow I got it from the Ovilus turn in
because those were world vehicles he got
into that little I did close to 500,000
factor line and never got the God role I
only got close once remotely near it so
I was very disappointed obviously and
that's kind of the thing about Lake the
gobbler all stats some of in this game
hey I want a good roll piece of armor I
want a good roll stat piece of armor
with the right affinity which at least
we can switch now and then a proper stat
distribution so if you're trying to go
for exotic I need the exotic I need ax
heist that roll and then distributed
away that's not complete trash and
recovery is too I've had those so
starting in season 11 it will be curated
both for relevance and overall size now
the size I stilts question because
there's a literally 30 on this list so
hmm to strike a balance between number
of rewards and the chance to get a
sought after drop every season gear from
previous seasons will be added in any
gear that would no longer have a max
power level greater than or equal to
should you say greater than because it's
not going to be the same the current
season cap will be cycled out to ensure
drops are powerful power relevant in
Season eleven so in theory the only just
for an example season twelve year for
the only things that are gonna be in
that world loot pool when we get to year
four are gonna be season of dawn and
onward
so nothing shadow keep noting and older
will be in there that's kind of their
way to curate that and make sure if it
does drop in there you at least can use
it at that time maybe not in two months
or whenever you get done with that
season but at least in that season it
will be
or valid per se now I made a list joys
of being bored not really depressing for
this and the list of things that we have
going into next season that are gonna be
in the world loop pool I also put the
list in my discord and somebody is like
there's a whole bunch of weapons I don't
care about interesting so here's the
list and I'm gonna go through and list
you guys by number as well just so you
guys get a point of reference yeah
Prescott that was you
oh no I got you auto rifles we have to
Uriel's gifted not hunger fusion rifles
we have three main ingredient ela thefor
fr4 and timeless timelines vertex hand
cannons we never have enough hand
cannons and we've got four old fashioned
dire promise true prophecy and nature of
the beast which is not the rate hand
cannon because God knows I've been
confused over that multiple Titans this
nomination nation interview I always get
that confused to adduce a so this is
like the year one or very old school
nature of the beast
so four hand cannons they're rocket
launchers to mass epoch and battlements
shotguns Hawthorne's toil and trouble
and wish bringer sidearms last hope
enigmas draw lonesome from gambit by the
way that's where we'll get into some of
this and last dance grenade launchers
we've got outrage of fortune and
interference so outrageous fortune is
actually coming into next season as a
current drop it sounds like right pulse
rifle G and seven last perdition sniper
rifle now that one's weird what's our
last perdition specifically is one we
could have just got done grinding for
with the fractal and yes so if I got a
good one there is this gonna be a season
eleven drop versus a drop coming into
some of the sense setting stuff we'll go
to that point sniper rifle distance
emulous tumulus and long shadow sword
honors edge and steel civil bow arsenic
pipe one breach grenade launcher
truth-teller that's an old year one
breech load since by the way like none
of those are coming forward and scout
rifles Night Watch just one one scout
written also from gambit run
yes so if you still need a weapon or
weapon role from the current Vanguard
crucible or game a playlist that isn't
on that list go grab it now yeah you
know was like and this is the quote that
got linked to me in my discord so Cosmo
replied cuz me and amongst everybody I
haven't tagged him in a question because
I was like I wanted to know what is
gonna happen with this world loophole
with regards to vendors armor armor will
come from specific activities like
crucible and gambit and turning in
tokens at the vendors but you will get
weapons from the world loop pool listed
from the inlet Wahb from doing these
activities or turning in the tokens and
vendors for example you might always get
crucible armor from turning in tokens to
shacks but you might get the gambit
sidearm from turning and crucible tokens
to shacks so we don't know anger yeah
right so my question is that being that
we've now got this or a loophole with
former items that were specific to
specific pools activity pools yep my
question then you know so does yeah bid
in you know like do they not have will
they not have a new updated specific
pole to themselves it does that sound
like it which seems like it's all
grouped together know how I feel about
that continue that's all of this bullet
points so this is discussion tonic one
go yeah ready the way that I understood
it and I guess I kind of hope that you
just explained it again was that going
forward italy's for next season or
whatever season they list that this has
this will be the legendary loop pool if
I turn in tokens at the gambit or when I
level up gambit or if I'm in at shacks
or if I tournament at Vanguard
presumably and then also any legendary
drop but then there's also this like
drop chance thing that they talked about
in the previous swab I forget what they
call that urate the kind of curation of
that yeah yeah that might be the is that
the seasonal one though I might be I I'm
forgetting I've been behind on a lot of
no use
but they talk basically it's like how it
worked in destiny one except it's like a
chance thing now rather than we're just
selecting armor or weapon right it
sounded really good in theory but to me
what this sounds like is that just the
legendary loophole in general will just
contain these these weapons going for it
for season 11 which is kind of a weird
design choice to me but mm-hmm I think
it plays into their their desire to
really control the sandbox because a lot
of these weapons are not good yeah do
you have an opinion sir because I know
you do yeah I'm trying to be open-minded
here um you know I don't like what I'm
hearing right again caveat there is
still information that I feel next
season still has to be presented that I
might not be aware so I I just want to
be clear that neck what's the name ex
season number season 10 or 10 or 11 XO
11
so with season 11 starts or blood is
Bungie telling me that when I play
gambit right cuz all I said let's just
say gamma for example all I see now is
knowing hunger in there right so they
say grab you know whatever is in the
blue pool now from these vendors because
you notice your lag go grab it now if
it's not on this list
so anything non knowing hunger and
whatever the other thing that's in this
loophole from gambit Night Watch is
their own Night Watch right yes is going
away so like let's use trust for example
Trust is on that part right so is trust
gone that's what it sounds like
trust yeah there's my rations spare
rations well spill can come from
reckoning second
that's like does rusted does reckoning
go away in the fall like this
is there a gambit perfected because they
said yeah gambit prime would last for
one year I am bit soul coming to Jesus
meeting is supposed to happen in the
fall exactly so to me again if you look
at it face value it seems weird as hell
I don't understand why this decision
choice - you know consolidate the pools
and then tell you anything that she
didn't get from the pools that still
currently exist that are gonna go away
you better grab right so to me it almost
feels like maybe the modes I'm guessing
now it almost feels like what we talked
about e which is like maybe cataclysmic
event of said activities I don't know
man this is very strange this is very
strange
it's a joke no it's design choice yeah
it's been I've been kind of just
browsing read it a little bit and the
balance changes are a whole different
discussion we'll get to those in a bit
right but just the idea that
specifically it's like it almost feels
like they're trying to give you like
freedom to grind where you want to but
by doing that they almost make the
numbers of the grind harder to get what
you want and also as other people have
said you take away the identity of
certain activities if I'm playing yeah a
bowl and that's one of the big ones is
like if I'm playing a crucible I'm going
for crucible weapons I won't have it
what what is anyone's incentive now been
to go play gambit yeah because not that
many people like that activity and now
if I can go get the viable weapons from
said activity I can go get mine on
hunger cuz auto rifles still apparently
are decent maybe right still we'll see
but if I can get that I could get it in
camp but I could get it crucible I could
get in Vanguard but I can also get it
with all these other things it's almost
like if you're in gambit I had yes I had
the armor in there but I also had seven
weapons to pick between well if I don't
have the armor and I have thirty weapons
to pick between so then trying to like
say hey the grinds easier to go after
something you want unless I can lay an
arrow down on like world loot pool I
want auto rifles that I can pick between
four right I really have to see this
thing in action because as you're saying
it's like and it does but the other
it takes the identity' way from
activities which is just a thing and it
also seems kind of fantasy because we
were told but we were just given this
whole thing about Sun setting right that
was the theme Sun setting and then we're
just sneakily Sun setting weapons from
an activity that we were told we were
going to get more time you know come
September whatever it is to rock out
before the infusion stops so it's just
weird messaging it's a lot of weird
message to go to of it this sounds very
good I'm just trying to understand the
thought process because my main beliefs
are you know activities lose identity
because one of the cool things about
playing gambit was like you know I can
grind for these specific you know guns
that I'm looking for bad or whatever
right each activity had guns tied to it
now we're doing everything in this Marsh
pot soup of a small cup of microwavable
chunky soup this is it get it well you
know it's just strange man I I don't
understand it you know I'm really trying
I'm really hoping that we're missing
context and that there is something that
is going to either be added next season
to each individual activity in addition
you know I'm saying to what this blue
pool holds because as of right now all
that you're telling me is hey we're
shrinking the you know loop that that
that's what you just told me we're not
Sun setting stuff until later so again
which which one is it what's going on
here so to to follow up points to that
so the first is I I find this weird that
they would basically these are all old
guns and so right now if you were to go
earn these guns some of these are
forsaken guns which means if you go get
them they will have the Forsaken symbol
on them and the Forsaken guns get sunset
in season 12 correct me if I'm wrong
yeah so but when they reintroduce guns
into the world loophole like they did
last season for like last hope and
Hawthorne's shotgun and a couple other
ones they
got the season 9 symbol added to them
which makes them viable beyond right
yeah you know in the future now at the
time we didn't know that but that's how
that's how it works now so presumably
these weapons down this new pool will
have the symbol for what is next season
which makes them viable longer so what's
really really weird to me is why would
you go tell me to grind for these guns
when they're all gonna get sunset after
the fact is such a weird thing and then
my second point to this is slurry I just
said it really good and well in one of
his recent videos and he's like bunches
like a control freak but they don't want
you to know that there are control like
they especially because they tell you
like Oh play the game you want to play
it this is an open game where you like
do whatever you want but then they
attempt this is a much broader point but
it was my Apple like they're basically
like really trying to control every
aspect of the game and I don't fault
them necessarily for a lot of the
decisions they make I understand though
I don't agree with a lot of things I do
I do understand why they do a lot of the
things that they do but a lot of the
decisions in the last few swabs that
they've been talking about I guess with
the exception of the ever verse one
which I think was just unanimously like
yeah good
and finally it's just like when I when I
like read between the lines and put my
cynical hat on yeah I kind of remove
like the emotional aspect of yeah
feeling about it it's kind of like this
to me just says that you really want to
control the way I play and that's super
frustrating because I already feel like
I'm being controlled and told how to
play especially is like an any game
player to where it's like I'm like I I
just I still can't play with some of my
friends I because of spamm for example
it's like one thing right but uh anyway
I don't mom I can get into it that's
like a huge philosophical but the it's
it's such a weird I don't know I don't
really know to think of this I guess
much like Sun setting which we'll get to
in a sec I I kind of have to see it to
understand it but there's definitely a
communication problem yes in regards to
this specifically yeah where it's like
why isn't this this I think this should
be explained very well but it's not
detail and it's not
there and again I hate to use word
sneaky but it it that's how I feel like
I feel like you know you are you listen
they have been a masterful job of being
transparent these last three or four
weeks right we're not gonna I'm not
gonna discredit them and now out of
necessity though yes there you go it's
out of this session because we're upset
and when we're upset and we stop playing
and we push back you know Daddy lessons
the rules also very sorry to get you off
they're very they're very good at this
and they've been this a lot in the past
and people don't catch on to this where
they'll intentionally announce what they
would consider bad news yeah and then
immediately follow it up with something
that's very hype yeah what's gonna
happen in two years about to say yeah
III was supposed to happen and even
though they traditionally announced the
fall expansion so they did this last
year to keep trying Guardian with a nerf
taller things and we all got about it
cuz shadow cube came out I didn't forget
it isn't just anyone a lot to were they
don't front load really bad news and
then Shelley after kind of just quietly
announced the thing and then not the bad
stuff right right and from a from a PR
standpoint that's like genius right oh
yeah yeah and increase the cycles and
these waves and for them it's
predictable and so they have some
metrics yeah this one's like a good news
sandwich because you had the adverse
then this trash and then we're getting
it trailers and reveals and high pipe
pipe pipe goodness it just ones in the
middle of the burger filling it's just
stuck in the middle so it's it's just I
don't know I I give the community team a
lot of credit but I also give a lot of
flack to because they have one of the
hardest jobs oh yeah but at the same
time I have to fopen a little bit
because games like or companies like
three four three or dice from
battlefront or even there's a couple
other ones they're community updates if
you go read them are amazing
like three four three ones for Master
Chief collection yeah it's like a
20-page essay and now granted I don't
expect everyone to read that we were
like don't break down like every single
problem they're working on excruciating
detail yes why it's like that one why we
needed to fix it or what we're doing
about it and then bunch is over here
sorry but they're like we're changing
the world loop pool and what I can't
really explain it it's just kind of
gonna be they're gonna figure it out
it's fine or the sunsetting thing - it's
like we're gonna sunset this stuff and
we kind of just feel like it cuz other
mmo's have done it we're not really sure
why we're doing it I mean they probably
know why they're doing it but you know
I'm trying I'm trying I'm being
facetious but I'm trying to get your
point there like other companies seem to
have this like like dice with
battlefront is that's like such a
success story to me because every update
was just like super impactful like
here's what we're working on here is
what we're doing
why don't you sometimes does that like
the last few weeks you know they've
given us a little more deep dive into it
but I feel like they just if they just
do that every week or like almost like
the week I'd be so much more happier
about destiny even if destiny was like
at its worst at least if thinking about
were like here are the problems let's
talk about it you know but they don't
and that kind of sucks and yeah I don't
think that at this point I've just given
up on expecting them to change yeah this
is um I think you're definitely got it
Teddy from the standpoint of again if
you look at it face value
you know without context of what's
coming
it don't sound good they found sneaky is
they're sneaking it feels deceptive I do
agree with you we are on the cusp of
next season content next season
marketing push next season trailer once
we get I can't we forget about all this
the message you know that the effort I'm
not gonna curse but you'll say that has
happened fry right because we're so and
then there's an usually some type of
introduction of a new system on the work
and I think that's what they ditched
it's this cycle we were in this cyclical
pattern with them that this is how it
goes and you know that the key with them
now is that people are on to it it's
been six years
like yeah it's it's it's like after a
while we start to understand the
cadences of how these things work and um
they're gonna have a tougher battle
because let I think initially you would
you say that for the most part I know me
and you had a little thing about exotics
but for the most part me and you want a
same page sunsetting had to happen power
creep the whole bit right I think the
consensus was everybody pretty much
agreed with that for the most part but
then again when you see things like this
and you hear about this loophole and all
this other stuff you know I'm saying
that kind of bring stuff in a question
and now people are worried and then the
last point I'll make before I give it to
he is that you know I'm not you know
what I'm struggling with job I am now
struggling with um reissue oh that's a
huge issue for me why why even you just
told us why this need to happen but then
you're going to remix old stuff instead
it just I hate to use this word because
you know I'm Pro diverse a lazy over
there yeah but it just feels like listen
I defend this game on anybody but it's
just like you know what people come up
to me and say that are non destiny that
our destiny haters dude they just give
you this content all over again dude
it's just repackage this is cursive
what's ours to play no dude this is war
mine 2.0 like they literally giving you
the same we're getting fell went to him
but it's hard to fight against those
guys that hate the game
because you know it what it like
somebody said I don't know where I read
it so technically we can get recluse 2.0
down the run down the road you don't say
like so what was the point and it
they've got to man I just don't
understand the thought process behind
reissuing when you just said yo
sunsetting has to happen for the for the
sanctity of the game makes messaging but
he I give it to you because I you know
I'm about to go in you know this is just
gonna build even more into sunsetting
and so I'm of the mindset that and this
is again where I may be leaning on the
other side of the fence from you guys
but I'm at the point where sunsetting I
feel like does need to happen we've got
come to an accord on Legendary's to a
point but even me some of the exotics
are either buff them or get rid of them
because some of them like literally the
Cerberus came up from Zinser today oh
yeah no fan I'm like when Dells the last
time I even thought about that gun yeah
thanks buff it or your if it make a
different auto rifle or something
because some of those things just either
need love or use I mean if there's a
point where I could at least hey I could
use Cerberus I could put like that type
of damage into a over load guy I can
just like kind of spray bullets at this
thing that's coming at me and I have a
pretty good chance to hit it no I still
can't use the the mod slot I'm gonna say
it every podcast yeah cannot use lots
lots in exotic still which bugs the hell
out of me
because you have things what if they go
to more long-range stuff next season
you're gonna have pulse rifles so
vigilance wing happens on lance that I
still can't go put those barrier
breakers in and I would just would be
nice to have a little variety since the
exotics go for it anyway you know we
know no I know so for me the biggest
thing is I don't want to keep using what
does the one I'm thinking of favorite oh
well that would too but that's a prime
example like I don't use mint I don't
want to see people using midnight ku in
year five
I shouldn't meet like go figure in here
like for yeah I had 45,000 kills with my
go figure
yes I found a replacement for it but yes
I know eventually it's not gonna be
viable for in-game stuff that's fine
like at some point things need to like
evolve and move forward but also we're
at the point and some of these perks
what we'll talk about in a second we've
had damage and reload speed be the main
things to as the drivers because you
want less downtime for your weapon
however you get to that one they've had
they've introduced like reload speed for
different ways and now they're literally
going to be nerfing all of them and then
we have damage perks kill clip rampage
multi kill clip outlet swashbuckler I
mean how many different ways you can add
damage to weapons but again they're
still like a worried about those always
being too strong right so my big issue
now as you're saying and reissuing but
also is my fear of what are they going
to introduce in the fall and I'm just
going to lead it into
and then we can kind of throw sun
setting and all this as well so they
talk about lock and reload and they
basically mention reload Park updates we
observed players lean towards parks that
increase their damage many no bleeping
curse words can be thrown in there or
reduced weapon downtime and again what
is everybody trying to go for especially
if you're going for aspirational content
efficiency what is the efficiency
I want more damage and I want less
downtime and again you want you want to
increase that DPS number especially if
you come from something like world that
DPS number is your sole goal I want to
hit the highest number of numbers on
that enemy that I can in the shortest
amount of time period mm-hmm okay cool
that's what everyone's to go for well we
already took the damaged ones down a peg
because those were too strong and
everybody wanted them well now we're
gonna do it for you know efficiency as
well the weapon downtime is going to be
greater the damage perks were adjusted
quite a while back for the reload perks
still don't feel like choices
this tuning Pass aims to keep them
feeling powerful ish without being so
dominant that no other choices seem
viable firsts some information just so
you guys understand they say reload
speed the reload stat is 0 to 100 and
then it maps on to that weapons
basically the animation speed of that
weapon it's going to be based speed or
increase up to whatever 100 is now
depending on whatever perk it is you may
get a perk like outlaw which used to
give plus 100 well it can't go over 100
so that would also add a scaler to the
animation so instead of it taking 100%
of time and then kind of multiplied over
they take another like 20% off of it
just to make outlaw run even faster to
make sure you always got some effect
from it right got it
all of these perks are going to be a
little bit less effective to bring them
down in line with some other perks most
of the other perks so you've got outlaw
the reload stat is going from plus 100
which would basically max it out to plus
50 now if you have something that sits
at 50 reload speed this technically will
in the reload stat would function the
same because the plus 50 plus 100 it
still caps at 100 mm the reload duration
scale is that kind of multiplier to the
animation they are taking that from
point
so 20% to 0.9 so a 10% reduction so
that's no matter what 10% slower plus
you're only gonna get plus 50 so it's
gonna be a little bit slower so that's
outlaw slowed it down a little bit
feeding frenzy this was strictly better
than outlaw so we're changing the
functionality based on the number of
rapid kills so with two kills it's equal
to outlaw the updated version with three
kills it's faster four kills it's the
fastest reload in the game except alloy
mag and then they said the max possible
duration scale was point eight three two
point eight so it can be fast if you get
four kills and the max possible reload
stat is still at plus 100 but they don't
break down everything they don't go plus
two kills as this and this plus it kills
us this in this they still leave the
vagary in there which we just got done
talking about they're like here's some
information numbers but not all of it
mmm rapid hit everybody's spare rations
that they wanted they wanted wrap it hit
rangefinder I have one of those by by
sheer luck by the way I didn't grab
right low gave a huge amount of reload
and stability for very little work it
front loaded the first precision hit
we've updated so it feels still feels
good but isn't quite as powerful again
that's almost like a contradictory
statement it's not as strong brace for
impact
bonuses to give less benefit for the
first hit and more for subsequent hits
max reload stat max possible reload stat
from 100 it's down to 60 so it caps at
that and again remember this was front
loaded so you would start at a hundred
versus the other or wherever it hit
first
max possible reload duration scale was
like 0.8 now its point 925 so it's more
than half a slow and the max possible
stat stability stat was plus 50 which is
huge for stability that's down to 25 so
it's definitely gonna feel weaker drop
mag situationally they basically made it
match outlaw field prep is unchanged but
they just gave you a point of reference
on it that it's reload status plus 50
and the duration scale is 0.8 so that's
the same and then alloy mag it's
unchanged but for reference alloy mag
the reload animation
is literally a third faster which is a
big difference so that one's pretty damn
quick there's some other perks in here
they mentioned they said they're fixing
an issue where perks grant partial
weapon ammo did not respect shot count
so they're talking about like pulse
rifles fusion rifles which the only
thing I could imagine is like Basti and
I don't know why those pulses or fusions
are listed in there and burst sidearm so
it fires multiples and it's just
multiplying weird
yeah so these perks these set perks are
going to be more common on the weapon
archetypes slide shot slide ways
ambitious assassins subsistence which I
don't care about most of those overflow
led from gold is okay clown cartridge
has potential so again if I can't have
efficiency at least my clip might be
bigger overflowing clown clown cartridge
I'll only - I see as positive they're
doing some perk tuning they are taking
dynamic selection but before you jump in
today yeah because I don't I don't want
to talk about the reloads yeah I don't
want to let them off for now okay do
this one I just was starving I went only
because I have another forget but it's
just again you read the initial
paragraph about reload perk updates
right Bungie says the damn they were
adjusted the dash press were adjusted
damage perks specifically but real Oh
perks still don't feel like choices
these are these words so when I read
that sentence you are now setting me up
for buffs you are you are now setting me
up mentally that good things are about
to happen for real overs and then you
consequently each sentence is is nerf or
you know it's still gonna be strong just
now but it just again messaging verbage
right what these are conflicting
messages you you you you go you
literally go through feeding frenzy
outlaw an old rapid hit and proceeded to
tell me how they are now going to be
worse in some way even if it's just my
Newt least statistically it is they're
going to be worse so I don't understand
why even say that these don't feel like
choices and now we're gonna do something
about it and then you do this so I'm
confused now the next segment I know
we're gonna talk about possibly buffs
but I
again it just bothered me I was a shot
to a sacrum I think he said the same we
were just like you know I don't
understand the thought process there
please help me
IIIi don't you tell you what do you
think they're just about the real Oh
stuff I'm I'm not backing out
I mean look I've said this a lot I said
it's you guys the smartest and best
players will always figure out the most
efficient way to do something back and
reload price and damage perks damage
versus that got nerves I believe with
the shadow keep update have always not
always they've generally been the go-to
perks a because they do provide that
optimal load out and be those perks are
also very easy to see in moments moment
gameplay versus something like Zen
moment for example or set more
satisfaction from it yeah yeah or
whatever right like like these perks are
you can see the effect of the perk
happening when you're playing and a part
of that is would like the vagueness that
Bungie unfortunately has a lot of their
perks like for example drew ski did a
video on moving target and I think
dynamic reduction which is like one of
the best explanations of how this works
function and those perks have been in
the game since d1 they were just changed
and due to slightly but they but they
existed but we never fully understood
how they worked until somebody sat down
and I don't know if he was the first one
but he was definitely one that explained
it the best from what I could find
and that's time this is a bigger point
where it's just like like they either
have it in here like they don't explain
all the different tiers of feeding
frenzy like why wouldn't you just that's
like four extra lines just read just
explain it's different yeah like I why
why does the community have to
constantly figure it like they just they
just finally broke down a misis like two
months ago in like super EXTREME detail
and that blows my mind because this game
has been around for six years as we know
a missus mostly worked the same in d1 as
it did in d2 so like why do I I it just
like really irks me when they like don't
want to give us this information I don't
understand why they're so afraid that
players will get upset now going back to
the reload stuff this is really
unfortunate and it's kind of a bummer
but I understand why they have to do it
but
again it's also just like why would you
tell me that you're gonna buff something
but then you like don't listen and shot
the Aires in Prescott we always go at it
that yeah I love those too and again we
get it right especially we know as the
tribe is gonna go on they're gonna
introduce new perks and you know we're
gonna talk about some other perks and
stuff like that but again you can't tell
people that you're going to you know
these things are not options we're gonna
do something about it
go bad ever in their favor again you
just gotta you gotta be more transparent
and you got a message a little correctly
because this way you won't get any any
any pushback any lash backs I'm just
trying to help
cuz it doesn't feel good but continue
observe yeah I mean that's that's
basically like its I understand why but
it's also like hey I this is like super
cynical to think about it this way but
unfortunately I have to think about it
with destiny I feel like they very
intentionally space out all the nerfs in
the last year like like they had this
all planned out for my year ago and
they've just like very carefully
strategically spaced it out month by
month very through bag so that way
people don't get like super super upset
yeah because basically since they did
the the reckoning nerf the right before
Guardian con I feel like it's just been
like nerf after nerf after nerf to our
overall ability in the sandbox like yes
they buff specific things and like auto
rifles or things like that but in
general when we were at pre July of last
year versus now like we as Guardians
suck yeah like we were just I mean on
the one hand that's an extreme example
because we were very powerful at that
point yes but at the same time like we
just keep going down and down and down a
pig and then this will lead into
sunsetting but like now you're gonna ask
me to regrind everything including my
armor and so it's like I'm basically
resetting but I'm it's it just goes back
to that fact of like they want to
control every aspect of the game but I
just let me play the game the way I want
to play the game yeah
like it shouldn't it shouldn't matter
and I don't know like the the some of
the buffs were a little bit interesting
and I'm stuck I put hipfire group on we
haven't gotten to that yet boy yeah from
it it was neither asked across or follow
it that was just like stop trying to
make hipfire grip happen yeah said that
I can't remember and I was just I'm
thinking the same thing and I love how
one of the bullet points is it has no
effect on sniper rifles like it
shouldn't be on there in the first place
at the first place
that's what's gonna say it can roll on a
sniper rifle and same thing with
shotguns shotguns can rule the outlaw
that aren't slug shotguns in a sleep why
does this have outlaw in it this doesn't
make any sense this is stuff like that
I'm like I'm not gonna put sneakbo on
sorry but I'm sorry if you're a bow fan
but guess what there there's like two
bows coming in after season 12 let's
introduce new bows so you're kind of
screwed either way so all of us are kind
of screwed
but even trainee is like when it comes
to bows I've literally used a bow in my
solo flawless round of shatter throne
I used a bow in my solo flawless around
a bit of heresy so like I find uses and
they give a little bit of a perk for
that ten percent PvE buff and I was like
that's literally why I put my NIRSPEC on
my bow and pit of heresy because I
couldn't one shot the Acolytes cuz it's
like I just know at least somebody
probably believe has that same feeling
as I do on that one
but again sneakbo that better they
better not do more perks like sneak fell
otherwise I will not be thrilled and I
guess this is my biggest thing like they
talk about dynamics weight reduction and
that's the big one between multiple
people they're saying hey dynamics where
reduction is already pretty good now it
adds ten stability over time on top of
the accuracy so this thing is actually
gonna be really solid for things that
are like continually firing bullets a
lot and auto rifles that take advantage
of this are gonna be just like potential
lasers if you get the right recoil
they're gonna be potentially good like
that's one of the good ones pulse
monitor you take critical damage now if
you swapped your shotgun it's literally
fully reloaded grow so like it auto
reloads plus fifty handling faster
weapons speed works on snowed weapons
was a cool hip fire grip I literally
look at them like I don't even care it's
adding like 1.2 times aim assist plus 15
aim assist plus one point seven degrees
precision hipfire angle Thresh
I'm going that is just a sentence in
itself just to say all of that I'm like
what the average person reads this and
going excuse me this is the point where
like I've seen the mercury is like the
the range cone and accuracy graph that
they'll do and like follow it's used
before and they've gone through and
those guys have done this and I was like
this is one of those points as you said
if it was a different company putting
this thing out hey this is what we mean
if you're up above this character here
at this point you would see this like
this if hip-fire grip was on your
reticle would be this much tighter it
would and that would be a way to like
show visually to say issue
representation every night you're like
two pixels off the dis dudes head but
you have that extra hipfire grip
aim-assist guess what that bullets gonna
curve and still hit him without it you
would have missed that shot and it would
have been body but what if bungees think
about the community and guys like for
like merkel you can have our video
that's what it is
think about the week letting them make
the content as opposed to clearly
explaining it to us they could still
make the video because not everybody
reads this stuff and people just follow
them but like if I sit there and read
literally plus one point seven degrees
precision hip-fire angle threshold no
the game is that is that act stated at
all much less when they talk about
dynamics where reduction they say add
ten stability okay I understand what
that's that means over time in addition
to accuracy where as accuracy stated in
the game know where it's on the range
stat yep yeah it was which is not a
number in the game has potential to be
cool if you get not all rifle with it
hold the hell onto that one because that
is potential pulse monitor you know that
point if you're gonna be running you
know an auto rifle with dynamics
reduction and pulse monitoring you like
shotgunning hey I'm running in a I got
switch switch Chuck it like you're gonna
be fully loaded good to go has potential
hip fire grip & sneakbo could have cared
less like if you're gonna drop me some
perk retuning knowledge don't give me
the two that are like people don't
really tend to care about them that's
just so a couple more things new perks
we're gonna be getting two new perks on
two reprised weapons next season sorry
about my tone of voice but oh that's
pretty obvious laying it on
dick they're thick there you go two new
perks are called iron grip and iron gaze
any thoughts of what those might do I
would imagine that iron grip has
something to do with stability or
accuracy and then gaze is probably like
a range thing but I don't know what they
would do cuz I don't know like I don't
know I read this and was kind of like
meh next paragraph like it's really
unfortunate that iron banner has just
been like like there it's like that like
up in the office that you like flick
little pieces of like paper into and I
think that's like like I will just flick
this this favorite it's like I will put
new perks on this metal satisfy the iron
in the power and will bring back this
armor from how many seasons it's been
eight seasons it's fine now we could
bring it back like this that's a really
prestigious way of looking at it but
like me that's how I feel like I treat
our in banner and it's really
unfortunate because I like iron banner
for the most part SP mm kind of sucks
but it's yeah I don't know what do you
guys think the perks are I'm just
writing out this way I'm very based
ability and either a scope on a rifle or
zoom I don't yeah again it's like I
don't know what they're coming on grip
seems like iron grip am I like is
handling lower but stabilities like just
rock solid or an idol again I don't know
if it's a give and take situation iron
gays we have the what is it the hawk a
one where you highlight people like I
mean I don't know if they'd ever even
get that creative honestly just picture
a specific scope like I don't I don't
know as a perk especially not like a
scope or a reload perk like an actual
perk is weird I don't know what that's
gonna do I'm very confused on that one
yeah pretty much the same I don't then I
put them in fear no yeah like almost
feel maybe gays the only thing I would
take a specific shot at is maybe gazes
what do they already have no
distractions cuz I was already thinking
about like uh you know what's the word
flinch kind of perk but um
they don't they don't like flinch perks
data like flee and Flint work sir no no
and bungees book I'm gonna be positive
and give them a little benefit of doubt
it hopefully these might be cool but
it's like Teddy said it's just like you
know just throw something mind bad his
way that flick you know it is just like
all right you know it's supposed to
satisfy us we'll see you know hopefully
these perks can be really cool and you
know we come up with some meta around it
tied to specific weapons and guns and
stuff and you know I would just hope
that um while we're getting these perks
that we get weapons new weapons inside
our vanity you of these burglar cat that
to me would be the ultimate coolness
there's usually a prized weapons there
they're new they're new for now they're
new this season I think it was a huge
slap in the face I think it was this
season that the armor they brought back
was the second time it was brought back
and that was like again I'm not a
developer so I don't I'm not pretending
understand along he's got a Mersenne
year-2 and year-3
but like really dude year three of iron
banner and destiny one was so good and
the armor and the what if even if you
just brought that back I would be like
cool I don't need a lore reason for it
to be back I don't need to know that it
was it was effort II that brought it
back just just I don't even salad any
have new voice lines you just put that
stuff in the game like you already made
it clever dragon was awesome like south
winds mercy act like there's it there's
just there's so much they could do and
it's like it always so close but so war
and so frustrating so frustrating and
again they just talking about reissue it
is like you they're sitting all in gold
mines of pigs in the vault that
literally could be reissued and the
community would have no issue right no
problem to see anything like like they
say we wouldn't care about the lore
attached to it we would just so be so
happy to see it and excited it's just
it's just mind-boggling to me you know
it like to me I think sometimes I again
again it could be resource issue but you
know it just seems that certain
just sitting sit and just decay and
we're like what's going on with this how
about giving this some love and it does
mean yeah EMG explained this season that
and this was shocking to me to hear this
thing anything
making the trials weapons yep was a
choice between having that or ritual
weapons this season which is why we
didn't get ritual weapon sissies and
besides the bow which was then later
confirmed that the bow was actually
specially part of the last season but
they cut it to introduce it this season
which means the bow was even made for
this season so they their resources I
guess are so tight they had to choose
between trials weapons and ritual
weapons and that when he said that I was
like whoa like what put you in
perspective I mean I guess if it's that
hard to make interesting weapons then I
mean perks are part of the problem too
but and trials a whole nother like slew
of issues that I don't know if you guys
want to get into that but that then that
was just like it's we hammered that nail
hard yeah unfortunate for them but yeah
I was like and that's and we talked
about it before when they said hey this
will be coming in season 13 you're like
hope you're happy for about six plus
months because it's not changing and we
also said it's like hey the cheating
needs fixed and if they fix a bunch of
other things they understand like the
loot and those are the things maybe
tokens aren't in there the bounties come
back all those things like come with
fresh stuff that would give it a little
bit of life because like if you just fix
like hey the trials loot pools better
while cheating still here I don't care
like they're they're moving stuff
farther out less those just want to get
these last few little buffs and they're
just literally gonna tie this all into
the big boy Tommy let's go
so the upcoming archetype buffs that
we've got slug shotguns getting PDE
damage of 30% Oh like like thank-you
ranks right high impact pulse rifles
picture your red ryx which you won't be
using for very long but still I know I
know
high impact poisons get and this is
again PvP so technically you probably
could for a while not aspirational high
impact pulse rifles this is where some
of the numbers that they go through
they're so small I remember the auto
rifle but off of like point zero zero
three percent or whatever you remember
that buff and like do you ever it's like
do you water
this or whatever I remember that but
yeah high impact pulse rifles damage per
bullet is from 21 to 22 now there's a
multiplier in there but they said this
changes from six crits to five crits and
one body to make them a little easier to
use mm-hmm but technically the kill time
is not different you just have a little
more forgiveness in it bopd damage
versus minors 10% thank you that when we
talked about this one I'm sure is gonna
piss off a lot of people because the way
I read this it's going the direction
people do not want let's go let's get to
it sniper rifles community feedback has
been that revoked and beloved dominate
yes we are fully aware that one and
looking at analytics they account for 86
percent of sniper usage in the crucible
and if we include other low zoom sniper
rifles that number gets even higher why
is it higher because a lot of people use
low zoom scopes and they prefer them
we're specifically looking at how soon
translates into ease of use for sniper
rifles we're looking into investigating
changes that make choosing a sniper
rifle zoom more of an interesting choice
yeah now I know how I read that I just
want you really laid on let me read that
sentence is how I read it but how did
you say it specifically first there we
go the way I read that is they're gonna
be like if you want to use low zoom the
perks that you get to go with that one
not gonna be good like if your sniper
rifle has a low zoom scope option good
luck finding snapshot sights opening
shot none of the good perks are gonna
come with that low zoom because if you
use the high zoom a then maybe you can
use those more fundrise but that's not
abuse but to get harder use that's
that's that's exactly how I read it -
okay oh you want to use a low zoom scope
because our maps are really small sorry
those coveted perks that you like it
really eases and guess what we're
sunsetting the old oh boy
oh sorry like what what kind of so
there's this little known franchise
called halo yes I don't think I called
just salt been here all night long
there's a there's a sniper rifle in that
game and also a little known fact about
that sniper rifle
it has doubles ooh yes you can zoom in
twice why is that just not an option
Oh y-yeah I I've been playing playing a
lot of Halo lately specifically Master
Chief question my brother is my
brother's a die-hard Halo fan that's
like his thing and so we've been going
we've been going through halo 1 to reach
and stuff and particularly reach playing
pulling through each again cuz that's
the closest thing to destiny since
destiny one was built off the reach
engine and yes things who built off that
I noticed a lot of similarities that I
had not noticed previously playing to
the game again particularly how the
weapons behave so for example the
grenade launcher in that game is
basically mountaintop roars or it's a
breach load it's a breach yeah because
because you have to release the trigger
to blow it up but the animation is
basically mountaintops reload and and
just like the way what like scout rifles
in the game the DMR feels the same as
scout rifles stuff like that and and
reach is not a perfect game by any means
but looking at that game it was like
you've got a lot of stuff right here
yeah and then you got a lot of stuff
right destiny one why is it wrong in
destiny it's been 10 years like yeah
it's just so frustrating but and what do
you think about the sniper rifle changes
I mean you guys were on it I mean the
only thing I would say is just that you
know this is their way of saying that
they're going when I but I read the word
we're gonna make interesting changes
make more separations are more of an
interesting choice to me then it also
means that these zooms that are hated
they are going to force those perks
though or that we like on those items so
that it will say okay well now I gotta
take it you know and again it kind of
goes back to your point any of
controlling you as a enforcing us down
paths that necessarily look like they're
looking at charts are very analytical
they're very they're very statistical we
know they're looking at usage rates all
these things and they're seeing that
these other zooms are not being utilized
right so this is their way of trying to
force us into that direction and it's
just you know this is what they do
that that being said the other zooms
aren't necessarily bad in their current
state the problem is that the the pvp
maps aren't designed for those zooms
particularly the long-range ones I guess
the medium one could you could argue
that for certain maps right and again
like a medium zoom sniper with snapshot
opening shot or whatever a quick draw
you know whatever perks you need on it
I'm not a PvP buff so I'm just gonna
fake we're talking here but like it's
still usable with the medium zoom maybe
not necessary the long range assume but
you could use it on certain maps so yeah
again just reading this it just it just
sounds like it's like alright you want
the short one you can have to use these
crummy perks that we made you get a
hipfire grip and pulse monitor I mean
I've been trying to gather as much
community feedback as I can have
listened to like every podcast about Sun
setting I've listened to when it comes
to like this one I was like asked across
and fall out and they're like don't
don't and even follow it was just like
duh duh don't go too crazy with our
sniper rifles it was that a time tone
it's like it's there this just came off
the sniper rifle PvE oh yeah smash yeah
nerve continues which was a buff that
they undid six months later yeah you can
buff that they undid a little bit later
when the adaptive auto rifle buffs
that's your 600 arts law arc logic suros
the knowing hunger the ones everybody
are using right now we're not rolling
back the season 10 buff per se but we're
adjusting the tuning a little to give
other auto-rifle subframes a chance to
shine so that was coming back down some
not although
but some hand candidates they said they
were valuing the hand cannon subfamilies
people have been asking about one tens
and one 40s forever because yeah fax fax
as an example were breaking out
aggressive hand cannons to let us tune
their range independently of others so
like Duke potentially yeah duels gonna
have a larger range for example there's
a criminal's dagger all that one-to-one
tend the one Chesney love I thought they
could do this already I feel like but I
guess like not it's not gonna matter
though cuz they're all gonna get sunset
like went through and cleared out most
of them in and still all of those like
but if you like the Duke so just like
this side of us knows come on y'all we
know new content is coming where they
gonna introduce new one tends to make
them it's the cycle we know how these
goals they brace it sounds awful now
what she does but they're braces for
impact cuz then they constantly see the
new stuff and it's something we remember
and it's pretty color its shiny it looks
cool and it's tied to some artifact
mechanic will come up with new strats
and I get it I get it just you know what
we go through
there's only good it to be Destiny's fit
so all this ties back in the last week
and now that we've got another party in
here so not the Sun setting so
before we get into kind of how some of
this stuff ties in I wanted to get kind
of Teddy's thoughts just on the general
thoughts of Sun setting any like
thoughts you've heard from other people
and just kind of where you stand at this
point on just the Sun setting going into
year twelve knowing what's not gonna be
available kind of knowing what is that
type of stuff just where are you
standing on the Sun setting idea for
where we're at so my initial reaction
when I read it was I was very upset now
I was not really playing a lot at that
time I got I was really busy with work
and so it's kind of just cutting a break
from destiny in general and it's been a
while since I've taken a break this long
and it's honestly felt really good but
when I first read that I was like this
is I'm not okay with this and I the more
I read other people's
takes on it and the more I kind of
thought about it as I would kind of go
about my day
the more I kind of like leaned towards
the middle but I'm still not okay with
it I I understand the argument for it
yes and I've I understand why people
have a very emotional attachment to
certain things I guess an emotional
argument if you will for it but it at
the cynical side of me is thinking this
is blended with a of just controlling
everything I do in this game and forcing
me to replay stuff and we've stopped we
touched on this earlier but I would have
been mostly fine with it if they just
didn't reintroduce anything thank you I
like and again we haven't so this is
like broadening the entire scope of what
I'm gonna talk about but like we haven't
seen it yet everything they're talking
about is just on paper and it could
change unlikely to change given the way
they report information to us but it
could change and it might not be as bad
as we think it is so I'm gonna give them
that if the doubt cuz I was gonna
benefit out but I'm also gonna be pretty
critical of it when it sucks or if it
sucks or if it's just doesn't not
actually right that being said so
there's this argument I wanted to get
into this so this is argument that the
Magic the Gathering argument the
constant gets thrown around the analogy
I guess if more people compare this to
magic together now I did not play I
never really put many other until until
about a year and a half ago I played a
little bit of Stephen Drew and James
Duggan I was visiting San Francisco and
we went we went to like a magic they
play a lot we went to like a magic PAC
event and very similar to Yukio which I
come for me you go background which I'll
also touch on because that game
functions very differently than magic
well I think that's actually a better
analogy than the magic set rotation
talked about actually so keep going okay
yeah so so imagine the gathering there's
what's called set rotation other card
games like hearthstone also implement
this I haven't played hearthstone so I'm
not super familiar that but the gist of
it is is that every X amount of time
there is a set of cards that are legal
in a certain format and then after that
time those cards get rotated out sat
familiar it sounds like a Sun setting
right like says this and Luke Smith even
compared it to Magic the Gathering is
director's cut well I think this analogy
is really bad from a like logical
standpoint given my background in logic
and my feels philosophical know what I
think it's a bad analogy because you're
talking about a card game that is a
turn-based game when you're playing a
turn-based game in a will remove the
tournament setting for a second because
there's a time limit in tournaments when
you're playing a turn-based game you
have all the time in the world like
chess right to make your move to make
your decision and pick what you want and
you know that in the confines of that
specific game that you're playing these
cards will all work but in the context
of destiny that's different because of
destiny it's not a turn-based game I
don't have all the time in the world to
make a decision and I need to actively
think about my loadout
based on a tivity I'm going into very
age and so that that kind of bothered me
a little bit when people work in
comparing it's magic in that sense when
people do one for one comparison to the
other path from so from a little bit of
logic lesson here for seconds analogies
are actually are like are the worst type
of argument in general because I know it
just really easy to break down yeah it's
you can make all the similar you can
compare it to things and have all the
similarities in the world but if I find
one difference your argument
automatically becomes weaker than it was
wow you know I hear that on this budget
keeps comparing mm-hmm they keep they
keep going oh they recently in last year
started calling testing MMO finally but
I'm finally right weekend wanting them
to do that and I don't know this is true
or not but I feel like it was Activision
who didn't want that label on the game
because they're afraid of their other
connotations and I understand that from
here and I was glad when they called it
out finally after all this time but they
they like want it to be an MMO but then
do things that are MMO ish and also that
are not MMO ish that don't work in
destiny so it's kind of weird like the
whole idea of Sun setting comes from the
MMORPG background and end car games as
well going back to the magic thing real
quick so magically got
was made by Wizards of the coast and
they have like I think 20 or 30 years of
experience yeah so they understand very
well how to rotate things in and out of
the game now where I'll bring you Gilead
Yugi was kind of unique car game and I
actually have experienced this because I
played you competitively and actually
freestyle it's not the Attic he played
he's the same when you play
competitively I learned about the game
through him yeah I played actually just
recently got back into the last year and
I stopped because of the virus
unfortunately I can't grow it you can't
go to events but I'm just I'm still
keeping up with it and kind of like
going into it and and so you guys very
unique because it actually doesn't have
a set rotation it has what's called a
forbidden banned list
it's where every every few months three
to six months depending on whatever
Konami feels like or what's going on the
meta they will either just outright ban
a card or limit a card or semi lay the
card and it could come back in the
future and that's kind of that's how the
crazy part about you go is that
technically you could use any card in
the game so long as it's not banned no
in an official tournament or even even
if you're just playing like casual as
long as you find that band there's only
one band list there's two official
formats but nobody plays the the second
of the two they just play the one that
has the bandwidth-limited list and so
what makes a super unique is Konami
every so often will unban really old
cards that will keep that at the time
that they were banned were really really
broken and like super super overpowered
but then they unbanned them and almost
almost always not always but almost
always they end up being either kind of
useless because I got power crept by
something that was better
lore they end up becoming good but not
broken because other cards have been
made to balance that that act and
obviously just like magic the gathering
was the coast Konami has just as much as
experience with or close to as with
making the card game so they understand
most of the time they have me some
mistakes in the past most the time with
how to make a balanced card so from
getting to this is long way and give me
the Bungie part so baby Bungie based on
prior experience and how they've nerfed
and buff things I don't feel like they
fully understand how to balance the
problematic things in the game they've
gotten close in the current state of
destiny but I feel like they always just
swing a little bit too far one where the
and so when you talk about set rotation
in the context of magic mm-hmm it
doesn't it doesn't necessarily apply one
for one to Justin yes there are
similarities and yes it could work but
where I am I sort of have a I've lost
faith in them is that they will they
will reintroduce perks that I care about
on guns or even for that matter reduce
the guns that matter because for me as
an optimal player you know if I have a
grenade launcher that is will say
hypothetically 80% of the max possible
damage I could do with that grenade
launcher right I want to go grind for
the grenade launcher that is best in the
game with the optics a fan when I and
when I finally earned that I want to be
able to use it for as long as possible I
understand I'm in the minority when I
say this because I from based on the
arguments I was seeing or the takes I
was seeing four people it seems like
people want new interesting things to
chase but for me I just want to get that
1% better when I get on ride you know I
want to grind for maybe a better
Mindbender so I want to go in for
bitters for rations and right that's the
content that's in the game so it I I
almost want them to do something like
what Yuya does where rather than doing a
full set rotation they just ban certain
guns or armor from specific activities I
don't know if that's possible based on
their they have in your defense they
have when an exotic armor is broken we
immediately get something out at the
same they could shut out so it yeah I
get in practice it seems as if they I
don't know from a development standpoint
they can do that with each individual
you know legendary stuff like that but
we have example I went fella went to
Rose busted bull shut down you know I'm
waiting for anteus wards thank you
continue though the end of it I like it
I I think I'm in the super minority when
I say this but that's that's just why I
want them to do something more like that
and I think Call of Duty did something
similar in a couple games ago I don't
really follow Cole did he were they
essentially inserting game modes the
players in the lab you could like vote
to ban a gun but like I would say like
as a hypothetical example let's say you
know this weekend of trials
hardlight is banned you can't be can't
put hard light on like you just can't
launch you can
launch trials we put it on and you can't
you can't put it on during it and that
way you get you get more like what's the
word it's more narrowed down data right
you can I'd they can understand rather
than having this set rotation I feel
like the cell rotation solution is
basically they're a solution to saying
this is how we're gonna make you keep
playing the game and the super super
cynical side of me is this is how you're
gonna keep play this is how we're gonna
make you keep playing the game in order
maybe make you spend money on the ever
verse story and we're kind of fixing it
so we got some goodwill back I've been
I've been like very cynical this whole
podcast but I just want to say like you
got it I respect a lot and I understand
where they're coming from but it's also
I have to look at it that way because
I'm on the outside and so or we're all
on the outside like we don't you know we
don't have that much inside knowledge
and they don't explain things so right
what I would pay to be on the inside
yeah fly on the wall I just want to
understand so many aspects of this game
and it sucks like Guardian cause they're
happening it was like yeah no no that's
the heart I missed the most you still
what I yeah a little discussion no I I
just wanted to wrap it up because I was
very long-winded for a call you dr.
joanne density I was lovely I love it
you you you had some major some points
here you know home it is it is very
interesting to me
you know um the thought process behind
the balancing arm is a very interesting
to see I think they don't have I don't
envy them like I understand it is a very
difficult process it's a very because on
one hand I do understand your points and
it could those things could solve a lot
you know because a lot of these things
if you look at other games and the
relation of destiny and you apply them
here some of that stuff could apply I
think also it's like there's a bunch of
hats here there's like the marketing hat
how do we sell this product how do we
get them excited you know whatever
whatever then you got the balancing hat
you know I'm saying which is like okay
how do we make this where it's fair and
things you know compete
and stuff like that and then it's also
like the investment hat now I feel the
investment hat is that is super
threatened right now and that is gone
it's gonna be polarizing that because
there's guys like you and there's guys
that I know that are also hardcore
lovers of this game and I get hit with
the same thing like are all I know is
taking stuff away and then bring it back
and then take it it's it's trying to
justify certain decisions are getting
harder and harder and again like I said
I don't Emily I don't want to make this
seem like oh it's just so easy all you
got to do is I know I'm never gonna
disrespect them in that way but um yeah
it is it is one of those things where
community feedback I feel it's getting
better I also feel though TUI's point
we're still in this super vague area of
still not knowing we've been this game
for so long it is unacceptable to me
that we still don't know how exactly you
know accuracy works are certain specific
perks why the secrecy behind the curtain
on this we've been with you guys this
long but why do you think this knowledge
is not worth disseminating alright do do
is it like you disrespect me it's the
intelligence of the game I don't
understand the thought process to not
explain in painful detail whether it be
through visual representation or
something you need to get people to
understand first what it is you're doing
what these perks mean then why you're
doing what you're doing it's a
combination you can't just give me one
or the other and then us the community
we're trying to figure this out
like you've got to steal again we would
take two step for us one step back you
do certain things with transparent that
I love and the Luke Smith directors cuts
I love I do you know it's just that
we've got to still let the curtain back
a little bit more and explain but where
you at with this man I feel I'm talking
now like full everybody have their
pieces on and so I've listened to as
many different thoughts on this as I can
between the anti Sun setting those
they're in favorite those are that in
fear
of what could go wrong those are just
like it's got to happen some they're
like if executed correctly it's like you
know picture six months after the fall
expansion all this stuff comes out it's
either gonna be looked at be like hey
they nailed it or holy crap that was a
train wreck it does some people are like
it's gonna be one of those some people
are like where's the middle ground for
this one and it seems like there's not a
lot of that mine's a weird point of like
be it magic you be at World of Warcraft
be at any of those references of things
not being available forever we had three
years of destiny one potentially that
was gonna be three years of destiny two
before dozen e3 came so we're in
uncharted territory period we don't they
are trying to navigate a ship that for
one they're just potentially getting
them feet their feet under them at this
point after they you know paid 160
million dollars to get away from
Activision they bought their own IP to
make sure they actually could do it and
then this season feels like a football
teams building season that's the best
way I can it seems like they're trying
to be like okay we got a look at the
draft we may not have that many wins
come on fans stick with us to be a rough
season this before in 12 I have hoped
this is fall expansion with things that
are building like the pyramid ships one
way or the other are going to be
involved now I have this weird little
thing about the pyramid ship wall that I
was thinking about recently it was like
I'm wondering depending on what comes
next season which Bay or Nate may or may
not be related to the quest that you
haven't seen yet if it's not related to
that still I'm wondering like I wonder
if the where the pyramid ships in game
is cuz everybody keeps saying Titan cuz
theoretically by math that's where
they're gonna end up you into the season
but theory what are they really going
for the big thing that brought him here
in the first place the traveler so if
you look on the map wall it's just about
as far for another season for them to go
from the wall in now the bunkers are
gonna go away which recently just kind
of Nick's that theory because we
wouldn't actually be able to look in the
bunkers and I honestly really hate the
bunkers are going away because they
could leave the one on the moon tied to
the quest did not actually delete the
quest but that's the whole FOMO thing
that they have
learned about mm-hmm
I mean when you take World of Warcraft
and you get a new expansion you go from
level 60 I've played and that's the
whole thing when it comes to like
respecting players investment you go
through the 40 person raid you do this
stuff you're going for the top level you
have spent all of this time giving the
top level gear you have a while to enjoy
it it could be like two years for an
expansion and they have like patches and
other stuff that comes and things do get
you know left behind basically but as
you have also said before it's like
there is a strew in this game they
nailed the literal psychological
attachment to a weapon it's different of
shooting a skate flog Duke a michael
figure you're bygones whatever it is
versus which acts with stats and numbers
on it that my little character you know
sprite is gonna walk around with that's
one thing but on the other side there is
a point of I'm used to working insanely
hard for this one thing and the new
expansion comes out and there's a lot of
new stuff but that's this is where my
honestly it like worry is starting to
arise with no it's just it's it's what
they can deliver no it's just the it's
how it's delivered and I think that's
where a lot of people are landing is how
does it land and this one this
specifically this swab actually made me
a little more hesitant than some of the
other ones because you take the perks
you take things like hey reload speed
some people were like why do you have to
knock it down versus bring some other
things just up to match it more
powerfully do you talk about Crower
creep to a point but I mean a lot of
people right now have said outlaw
doesn't feel overbearing like out the
reload yeah you want those but again
like recluses too much but also you know
sneakbo sucks it's true but somewhere
it's like what I'd rather have the sneak
bows come up like if you're crouching
your reload speed is twice as fast be
like dude if you can actually crouching
go pew pew pew like if they bring some
stuff up to be more powerful but not to
a point of being broken and I guess if
there's trying to still bring things
down my worry at this point is how
exciting are the perks going to be in
the future how creative can they get if
like they have reload listed in 1 2 3 4
5 6
different ways but they're even
adjusting here and all of the reload
perks are potentially going to be
brought down more things are being
brought down
we've got dynamic sway reduction which
is the only thing that actually sounds
positive I was like pulse monitor
situational but general use dynamics
like the only one that's like that
actually has potentially about you
how many more honestly I'm wondering
like are there gonna be new archetypes
we got the wave frame grenade launcher
for example Marty's murderous
retribution but that was a new thing
okay yeah like that I mean honestly at
some point I would like to see that if
it takes them making new weapon styles
what if there's an arc version of that
you shoot out this little thing and it's
like a little storm grenade there's a
void one somebody was like hey you shoot
out like the like a black hole effect
for void and some of those could be like
just unique weapons for them to add into
but again when it comes to the perks if
we're gonna be getting new weapons and
same thing for like world if you get new
stuff it's got to feel fresh in a
different way like the this expansion
has felt the emptiest in changes of it
we got the moon no this whole shadow
keep expansion we didn't get in major
new perks like literally the wave frame
grenade launcher for the past year is
the probably the most unique thing that
we've seen yeah but I think good in
their defense look didn't they get we
get for pool and firing no fires I did
exist there were quite a few new perks
added last season some of the some of
the clown cartridge existed in destiny
one yeah that was replies abut we did we
do get a fair amount of new perks I
would say about the same amount that we
got and Susan The Drifter which was the
first time they introduced new perks is
forsaken I think at that point but to
your point which I think I touched on
this is my biggest fear is that I'm
afraid that they like sunsetting in
theory will work but if they don't
reintroduce perks or functions that are
equivalent or better in some way that
incentivized me to keep playing the game
then it's it's the Thanos paradox
problem and I mentioned on the last time
like oh yeah I already knew what existed
and you took it away from me and now I
have to get it again which that's where
I have the problem if you reskin it that
doesn't fix the issue like it has to be
something better
and then you can take it away from me
because then I understand oh I'm gonna
get something better in the future but
to just take it away from me and give me
a Rekluse 2.0 that has it's effectively
the same thing that that doesn't cut it
for me like and we have to see it like
yeah yeah I'm being a little hard on
them but mm-hmm no they just died Munich
ate this stuff like it's so frustrating
I was like I mean and that's the thing
for me is like the worry is they reissue
something that I've already got and you
know when you say like the yugioh ban
list if I have an old spare rations and
that comes back into being an available
weapon I can joint get out of the vault
and I can use it again as opposed to do
we've a tree you should spare rations
and this is what one of the it was I
think testing firing range they were
talking about I don't want to take half
that look at a god role in my vault that
I'm just like I've held onto this thing
it's like amazing cool I don't want to
see spare rations 2.0 yeah have that say
and you have to go through it again
so the reuse is one side but honestly
and this is where this is just where
it's on unbunch II we played a lot we've
gone through a lot of different things
and my hope that the fall expansion is
huge like because I feel at this point
it has to be shadow keep was five
missions and yes we got the moon but
like it didn't touch the Forsaken or the
taking Kings it wasn't there it was no
it was good it was checked but it was it
wasn't it wasn't forsaken love yeah yeah
but it was like it was like rise of iron
yeah yeah yeah it was your rise of iron
and at this point since there doesn't
seem to be a Dustin III on the horizon
we still need that taking king or
forsaken moment whether it be you know
the reintroduction of the Forsaken
subclasses and the arm the weapons with
random roles we need some substantial
change because right now if it's just
like two perks or reload in a scope if
it's these two perks and if they do give
more of just two perks I am just worried
as they're as they're trying to keep
things so tight right now
mmm but like if they do introduce
something will it be will it live too
strong for too long and then go away or
just I'm worried that a lot of the stuff
that we introduced outside of like maybe
the pursuit weapon or something
of that nature are not going to be
enough it's not gonna be strong enough
not gonna be standout enough for the
stuff that's being sunset as you guys
have all been saying so it's not Bungie
for me at this point to prove me wrong
because in like I don't want to keep
having whisper even in the game but it's
like I don't want to keep having these
things keep coming forward like at some
point I do want to go after new stuff
I'm I'm of that opinion I just want to
make sure the new stuff is something I
desire that's my one major worry and
seeing the stuff of them slowly inching
these perks down and closer and but not
anything getting much more powerful as
you said we've been at our weakest point
for a little while now if we keep
feeling weaker and weaker my brother
said it - he's like my hammer head my
yotan my blast furnace are all going
away yotan is gonna stay but the other
two hammer head blast furnace I love the
way sound with a little the way I feel
and everything they feel like they're
getting weaker and the enemies seem to
be keep getting stronger and he's like I
feel like I can't do I feel like I'm not
that strong in the game and I never get
to feel that strong and I'm worried it
with what's introduced in the future I
don't know if we're gonna get that
feeling likes you know Guardians
actually come back so I know it's a long
winded way to get there for everybody so
I'm sorry mm-hmm apparently this has
been the long winded discussion all
night long for everybody but this is
just mine has been this reading this one
and thinking about this one I still want
the Sun setting but like I am very I
wonder if they're gonna be able to
deliver stuff that's truly as desirable
as I would like in my head no I get it I
mean both you guys been a fantastic
points and and that is you know the
trust we have to have in them right at
this point that's just where we are we
we are literally hoping that you know
what is it that old spider-man
expressing with great power comes great
responsibility if you want to take away
this stuff you know we're trusting you
to do the right things to make sure that
these new things that are introduced are
super desirable because I'm of the
mindset of Teddy in this respect I'm
gonna first chase after things that are
the most efficient right that's me if
people if that the numbers breakdown and
this new weapon is desirable because you
can do either DPN or whatever right
that's the more the second reason for me
is you know I do like the power fantasy
and I
you like just cool things right you want
things to be cool you want things to be
exciting like when not that wave
whatever breach great long lunch at the
Marty's was introduced that was new that
was fresh I hadn't seen anything like
that you know so it's on them to have
this this this pool in reintroduced you
know and stuff like that now we're I'm
also wearing yeah it's like if you're
gonna tell me in my vault
I have like right now basically how the
way I play is even there's archetypes
that I know in the game that are
terrible right now rifles rocket
launchers not much it's all by the way I
did want to say that scene at all but we
get in it but you know Scout like I
would I get a god role drop of those I
immediately put it into the vault cuz my
feeling is the hope of that sandbox
change that buffs those archetypes right
that's the same thing
yeah like okay I don't use this more
terrible type you know man I got this
you know breach right here that's got a
card role I've got this one you know
this one forty this one ten hand cannon
it's God role if they ever come back
yours and like bull so now with the Sun
setting those are gonna go and the hope
is that when these the new things get
you know entry introduced I mean new
things that get out come out you know
we're gonna get stuff just as good and
again the issue I also have is the
regain that the reissue ban because it's
not a good feel like I said if you had
it you take it away and then you bring
it right back without the emotional
attachment without the skin without the
and then here's what my no one's talking
about when they introduced when you get
a weapon and you got that little slider
and it says track it PvP kills track
your Peavy he kills what's the point now
[Laughter]
that's really yeah the thought process
then is we want you to have an emotional
attachment ISM we want this to feel like
it's yours
these are bungees works right we ate
this whole
what process completely contradicts that
right they're gonna be finite a number
of tools before we could I have to get
rid of it so again sorry you got a
couple points that so first off I just
recently hit I got a month or two ago a
hundred thousand kills on recluse in
people and again I understand that I'm
in the super minority when I say this
but I to me I don't need interesting
guns to put to play the game I just need
the most optimal thing for the thing I'm
doing and I'm totally satisfied with
that so at the moment it's my typical
mountaintop recluse Anarchy is your the
one for PvE
which is ironic because that was the
load up before sniper rifles and then I
got buff him like oh is it augurs Burton
is not the best thing and then they got
under if it's like well they didn't nerf
these so I guess this is fine now yeah
so it I understand why recluse has to go
but it also really sucks because I have
a hundred thousand kills on that gun so
like what's the point now it to me it's
just like well I might as well just
delete this like yeah I had an
attachment to it I'm not going to but
I'll tell you what if they reintroduce
you Rekluse I'm gonna get it but I'm
gonna piss because it's gonna be like
why did you do this my second follow
point was so yeah you said that kinda
you know you said that you hoard weapons
like I do like if I got a God role of
anything I generally keep it even if the
weapon is absolute trash because there's
always this chance and after doing this
assess anyone who's always this chance
that that gun could get buffed in the
future that arctan could get buffed in
the future and then I'm sitting on a
gold nugget basic yes yes like that gun
might not even be earnable at this point
in the game yeah I don't know that's
happening either of you but when it's
happened to me that's like one of the
greatest feelings I was like we did
reckon yeah I went through and I'm like
I need one of those and then somebody's
Linklater hey this thing's apparently
really hot right now this is the role
you're looking for and I posted in
Twitter and they're like I have this one
is this in there like that's the god
role leave me the hell alone I was like
oh and it was just sitting there and it
really okay so the other side of this do
you have any other points I had one more
it's kind of related so if you've
noticed deej and the other PR managers
don't say this anymore but they used to
say it's always a conversation it's
always a back and forth but bungees
never actually done that if you really
think about how they've communicated
stuff to us in this game the entire
lifespan of Destin even before destiny
came out all they do is tell us
something we react to it negative or
positive and with the exception of a few
instances such as the artifact yes
generally they generally don't change
why they save us
they just tell us what they're doing and
then we have to accept it the way it is
good or bad that sucks
like that is such a like I'm sorry but
that it's like such a backwards way of
doing it the way you should be doing it
like an other developers like dice or
through 4/3 is hey we're thinking about
changing soil yes what do you think
about these potential changes and the
community goes well I speed run with
this sort and that would ruin the
experience of speedrunning which has
become a kind of a close-knit but large
community of destiny in fact the recent
as the region's recent gdq featured in
the last witch speedrun which when the
first time destiny showed up well I was
super cool to watch Wow but you can't do
that anymore because they nerfed
worldline zero that like 0.1 percent of
all players were using to speedrun the
game for no reason like nobody asked for
that nobody wanted that it wasn't
necessarily breaking the game like yes
you get out of bounds but it didn't like
help you in any way for anything that
was major and so stuff like that
like when they announced the sort
changes I was like cool they're gonna
change swords and then immediately it
was like why wouldn't you tell me that
six months ago when you were thinking
about this so that I could like or the
community in general dumped like yeah
that's good or bad and it's in there to
the credit they are talking about
sunsetting i guess early since this is
gonna happen in September but I don't
think anything will change based on our
feedback like I and if it does we'll
never know because I'll never tell us
that which is super frustrating that's
so that like perks me so much internally
because it's it's just like like no
offense to them but it's like bad PR in
a way like bad PR management it's like
just explain to me because the same
through the perks stuff like just go to
the dev that made the perk or handles
that perk and tell them write a one
paragraph explanation of how
moving-target works right cool now I
have a reference for the next five years
on how moving target works and I don't
have to like go to the podcast of John
wise new ski explaining
one for that's that's the one they
always reference for crucible radio it's
the only time that range was ever
explained they have tempo recently and
it's like that's crazy to me that that
was a long time those explained it I'm
gonna keep it like this still perks I
truly don't understand the entire nature
of them yours there's still there's
still perks that I don't know and take
your last one I gave it back to you I
don't use it at all it is is you set a
point like I said I know I'm in maybe 1%
but it's such a feeling like you said
earlier win again you stash that
non-used archetype and it for me you
know what it really hit it was um when
when six hundreds got buffed and I
pulled out like a god Road Gilliard from
black hungry and I'm like oh I'm ready
Bailey like you know say it rewarded me
because I recognized it and I so with
this thing you know I again am I gonna
adjust and move forward absolutely but
it does hurt that aspect you know I'm
saying I'm holding on to stuff and then
with the hope that if the sandbox
changes you'll be able to utilize these
things it's almost like a reward for
your for your diligence and for you you
know I'm saying for your investment it's
a game like yeah you know I I'm gonna
keep this brief but like I honestly feel
like they do not respect the players
time despite saying that a lot that was
leading in actually I don't think they
do one of the biggest things for a
counter to people not liking weapons
sunsetting so you take something like
Mindbenders which is a perfect example
it's in a nightfall the drop rates
really low then you have to try and get
the right roll and it's a pain in the
ass strike and the dude hasn't like
there's so many things wrong with the
Mindbenders grind that is one of those
where they're like fallout talked about
it forever that he didn't have a
Mindbenders for the longest time he says
he's got one I think now but like how
many times or the people who go and play
reckoning like forget which one said it
and they're like I start my stream with
that every day working on certain grinds
and they're like I'm trying to get this
thing so the argument there and it might
have been kami cakes I'm trying to
reference all the right people so I
don't steal anybody thoughts but the
idea behind that is like
okay so if you're gonna make things have
a window of aspirational usability but
then the grind for those needs to be a
lot more like player-driven
and you have choice over what you're
going for if I do a flawless trade
exotic from the raid like if I do the
hardest difficult to take something like
Menagerie which is still the pinnacle of
all activity it's just cuz that was so
amazing but take the chalice and I was
honestly wondering if you could take
that a step further okay so if you do
normal menagerie you might be able to
narrow it down to the auto-rifle
okay so if you do heroic menagerie then
maybe you can narrow it down to the
Rangemaster work or the archetype that
you go for and like the harder
difficulty you do with something so the
people or you have yep the more you can
like narrow it down and what you're
grinding for so then the casual players
like hey I can go get this Auto rifle
cool I got one nice
they don't may not have as many people
to go for but again they're also not
trying to cool the ultra-efficient teddy
who's doing that but he's like hey if
Teddy's like hey I got like five people
we're gonna be on a menagerie we're
gonna crush this thing no one's going to
die I can if if you get flawless you can
put in a fifth gym and you can get like
almost the exact perfect role you're
going for oh and you can go like deep
deep deep on that like driven diet just
because your skill gets you there and
guess what Oh to get to that flawless
run you've probably run that thing 20
times in the first place between deaths
and other things so you've already
grinded some in the first place and then
when you finally do get it's like the
carrot at the end of the tunnel or a
carrot at the end of it but you know if
I can get good enough if my skill can
get there then I know I can achieve what
I'm going for and that was the thing
when it comes to World of Warcraft
there's a bow for a hunter and I
literally would log on to I log onto for
other people's accounts to get this bow
for them mmm because the quest you had
to go through I don't know if you know
what the word kiting means do you if I
say that I do you do you don't so
basically yeah basically what it means
is I'm like I'm constantly running away
from I'm basically dragging somebody
like a kite behind me but I'm always
making sure I'm keeping my distance and
we can wait you had to get this beause
you had to do it four times and he'll
know the emblem wasn't enough for pit of
heresy just like solo flawless bit of
heresy and that's another one like you
go solo flawless
of heresy thank you I get an emblem I'm
like you're telling me I can't get like
a piece of okay that drops with like 12
armor and I look like you know I look
like it's okay like that type of stuff
but the idea of kiting is like I had it
was hard enough that most people are
like I even got the first part of the
quest but I can't go finish this quest
and I'm like alright so I went through I
figured out how to do it knighted I'm
helping other people but you had to kite
for people through like half of a World
of Warcraft zone which is huge and you
had to do it in four different places
around the world that was a really hard
thing to go for but as I finally figured
it out and I spent hours on that stupid
quest I got it that was one of the best
bows at the time and I could achieve it
if I was skilled enough to do it same
principle there is like if there is
seasonal act Purohit insert seasonal
activity if there is a hard version of
that in season 12 when the Sun setting
happens if I can go after that then at
least I know I can get that reward so
the biggest thing people want is the
player choice to say hey if the
Mindbenders is there and I want a good
role how do I get the curated well you
can run the nightfall flawlessly right
crap that's gonna be hard but if they do
it I know I can get the curator a
totally shot my hitters yeah there is a
limit to how far that orangy can screw
you so that's one of those things when
they were talking about the biggest
piece of them spending four months there
logging in on reckoning every single day
on their stream and not getting what
they're going for
it makes the sunsetting feel worse
because shortens the time table they can
use it by however long it takes the
grind if when it releases like dude
we're ultra skilled we knocked it out
cool I can enjoy it for 11 months in two
weeks because I got it in the first two
weeks of the new season then they know
it's like hey I've got this cool done
and they're gonna keep stuff going so
it's the the way people go after content
in the fall is gonna be another
determination for one it's got to be
desirable and to the player choice of
how they go after it
not just flipping a coin and again this
is why me reading this table of the
world loop pool seems bigger and a
little more varied as opposed to just
the gambit guns or whatever it is like
it just gave me weird feelings on this
one so I'm I do want the Sun setting but
man they have to deliver so sorry for it
yeah it's a lot
this is fine the last point is you know
manao a lot of things he and the thing
is we got it we got a call how it is
it's also time I'm III preach this
during my you know initial push back
with um it when a retirement was just
time investment man you've got to
respect players time you know I mean you
you have to and let's be real right
when time investment is not respected at
least that you know discussed and it
leads to people exiting the game we you
know two of three here have not played
for seven we consider ourself our core
you know saying for for that lack for
that reason so it's up to them you know
saying they have to dock this out the
part they have to nail it because
ultimately what what will happen you
know shout out to get value shout to a
lot of people as people say hey you know
I'm not for the respected I'm out that's
just how it works you know saying and
it's that but they've got they've half -
nailed it because you can't do this to
people it's like cyclical abuse you
cannot continue to do this to people and
expect hey baby take me back hey baby
take me back and I said no at the point
people are going to say no but isn't it
that's again I don't I don't want to
disrespect them I don't envy their
position it's none of this stuff is easy
and flip switch I don't want to make it
seem that way but they if the onus is on
them to really really knock this out you
know saying because again if you do
that's proven we come back we're excited
we like to read the new direction you
don't say stuff like that so it's a
tough thing because and it's not the
press go you made a good point the other
thing too when I will admit because
again we're the community we don't know
everything there's some there's some
things that in our minds we may think is
the right way to go you know I'm saying
and for their for their thought process
because they have the data there they're
not telling us or they have you know say
they may have legitimate reasons right
as to why certain things can't happen
and so on and so forth but because of
the lack of transparency behind the
curtain we don't know which leads us to
speculate the
they don't know what they do good
help us help you you know what you gonna
say like hey somebody mentioned in the
chat community something you know these
are the things help us feel like we're
having that dialogue like Teddy said as
opposed to daddy said no daddy said no
you know each said no you got that dad
what does he do we all pull it for the
Stig but uh we'll see we'll see I see
so in destiny one and there's a lot of
points I want to make I'm trying to like
keep up with everything you guys had
some pretty good stuff so unless anyone
there was this problem of I don't like
using this phrase but this is what was
happening the rich got richer right
whereas you the more you played the game
and the more hardcore you were at
destiny one you got better and better
stuff and it was very hard the Buried
entry was very high and I had a goal
experience with this was to my really
good friends who jumped out of the game
shortly after taking Kane came out and
they played for a bit and then they're
not the greatest gamers like they played
very casually but they enjoyed what they
played and they're the two big
Borderlands fans so they come from war
lands background and they just wanted
something new at the time because
borderlines was kind of rut during that
era right and they kind of gave up on
the game around the taken overpass
taking the spring update because it was
just too confusing and they ultimately
couldn't end up they weren't able to to
continually pursue the hardcore
activities to keep the loot trials raids
you know all that's of the brigade and
so here comes d2 which obviously was
designed with the intention for casual
players and to broaden the scope and I I
feel like the current state of destiny
to is really really suffering from that
design of philosophy because they're so
afraid to give a good player a reward
for doing something difficult and it's
so bizarre to me because it ultimately
especially sunsetting it won't matter
right like like if I if I did a Grand
Master nightfall and the Grand Master
nightfall if I do it in a certain lot of
time with certain tasks or if it Garrett
it guarantees me you know some really
cool drop-in strikes that currently
don't exist all the drops that strikes
are just not
I should get that drop and if someone
this is gonna be hard to hear for some
people but if you're not capable of
doing that whether you can't get the
people to do it or you're not skilled
enough you don't deserve that
like that's it's just that simple like
if you're not good enough to go to the
White House this is another prime
example sorry you don't deserve the loot
but now I'm not saying you shouldn't try
right you should have the mindset of
trying to get better I I can attest to
this because a destiny one I was
terrible at PvP and the only reason I
even touch VP before trials of Osiris
came out well schools I played I played
on banner once why I made the mistake of
not getting felwinter's during the iron
banner because that was the busted
felons reason I played and I didn't get
it and then trouble Cyrus came out and
was like I want to get better at PvP cuz
I'm really bad at this game TV and by
the end of destiny one I got a little
bit better and then destiny too rolled
around and there wasn't a lot to do
during the first year destiny - so I
played quite a bit of a TV play trials
and I got better I just could be better
I would not say I'm a good player but I
definitely I I don't necessarily have
the urge to get better but I wanted to
get better because there was Luke 9
doing this effective difficulty
investment and so again if you aren't
skilled enough to get the reward I don't
think you deserve it and for whatever
reason in destiny - I feel like Bungie
is just so afraid to give that I think
that's why trials flawless doesn't have
anything special tied behind it because
they're like if we put something special
behind it people are gonna get super
upset they're not gonna play a game
newsflash people aren't playing trials
with Cyrus because a bunch of other
things are wrong yeah so that doesn't
even matter in like the grand scheme of
the pageboy people are still pissed
about the chestnut/black valuable yeah
you get night fault both like Grand
Master night falls and trials you get
like materials that you would need to
use to get there in the first place to
be as efficient as possible and rules on
exotics which we've already probably
you're going in there with an exotic
loadout the first place you get nothing
of benefit and the raids are the same
way like garden of salvation like perks
nothing has stood out on raid weapon
perks since probably be one I feel like
packs
I mean rim limit midnight coup
initiative beasts I would
the only to raid yeah excluding exotics
are the only to raid guns that have
mattered at some point during destiny
two's lifespan the rest of them the rest
of them could have been good or might
have been good but they weren't like
yeah I mean you're we're gonna put them
on like what's behind a well man that's
you couldn't have said it any better
because any better yeah like I mean you
take the hard [ __ ] you take that really
hard thing a while I'm talking about hey
that's one of the best pose in the game
I had to work my ass off for it but I
did same thing you'd do a raid you do
trials like me I like going to flawless
trials seems like you I would like I
would have to start dedicating weekends
and working for it and the progress
would hopefully come but that's one of
those I would have to work on improving
on but even if you like have a decent
group and can run into a raid and you
get through most of the encounters right
now I think one of the reasons I haven't
rated as much is because the incentive
isn't there when you can still get a
rampage when might go figure my dad
bought rifle that I got a lot of crap
bored that's like I can that thing is so
damn good oh good the way it feels for
me like I are there weapons there's a
rampage outlaw pulse rifle and garden of
salvation it might be the same right but
not better and that's one of the weird
arguments for Sun setting is like these
lateral upgrades I'm like I don't want
lateral upgrades anymore I am tired of
those I don't want another one of those
so I know you're getting you're itching
to say something so I'm gonna give it
back to you today I just want to say cuz
you do at one point that I'm absolutely
loving what you said which is again we
know how they started with d2 with the I
want to call it the casualization so cuz
in d1 like you said the issue was when
the hardcore again sort of caught the
rich got richer right they didn't I
guess like that and maybe the casuals
kind of veered away because they felt if
they couldn't keep up boom but now
sunsetting kind of alleviates that so
let's bring back that you know super
reward that that incentive for the
hardcore content to be better right
because at the end of the day if they're
so worried about that you're gonna
sunset this stuff anyway
you know so I think that's why it should
swing back adapt the pendulum in that
direction for the pinnacle activity like
that but I'm giving
because he was on fire but so the final
point I wanted to make and you kind of
lose it to this so so yeah it would be
great when something happens for me you
know if I'm if I'm capable of doing the
activity in the weapon but I'll present
you with a scenario that I know will
happen to me because my RNG is terrible
what happens when six months into the
year I finally get that gun from season
12 that I've been chasing and now I only
get to use it for six months as opposed
to 11 months right like think think
about fellow hunters for example
Bellinger's came out at the very end of
the season but it's still tied to this
season which means you don't get to use
it through the following season in the
next year that takes place at the same
time it only will be good up to that
season right which means you don't
actually get a year you get nine months
to use it so it's kind of this like
weird scenario like think about the
world loophole - I still don't have a
god rule last last hope I'm probably
never going to get a god rule lasso
because the chances of me getting to
drop first of all or astronomical and
then getting the - right perks on it are
astronomical like it's just not gonna
happen
so what happens when me as a hardcore
player who will dedicate a crap cent of
time to doing the activity that I want
things from but I don't get it and then
it goes away
and I never got it like that that's why
I'm really worried about cuz they they
they do this already kinda with triumphs
and I don't like that like it's just
just leave it I understand certain
things can't be left in the game but for
the most part just make triumphs that
are capable of staying in the game and
it's fine guns a little bit different
but my greater point was like that
scenario is going to happen not just to
me it's gonna happen to a lot of
absolutely and it's gonna be terrible
mmm we'd have to see it happen and
unfortunately they're iterative process
just operates at that speed but it will
happen and will be interesting to see
how they handle that issue I think
that's where the reissuing of guns might
come into play but what also arcs me
about that is they mentioned that before
shadow keep came out the artifact mods
would be experimental mods and some of
them were some of them were yeah and
they said that after the season they
would take a look at the mods and then
reintroduce certain mod based on usage
back into the loop pool they haven't
done that at all and the artifact has
basically just been the same mods every
single season with the exception of a
few and then obviously the the guns
change depending on you know what were
supposed to use so if you apply that
same logic and philosophy to the
reassuring of guns does that just mean
you're just not gonna reissue them
because you've already failed to do it
once it I don't know it's I'm very
worried but at the end of the day I'm
still gonna play the game and I'm still
gonna you know hopefully enjoy it but I
they always had this monkey paw problem
if like there's always a king hatch and
that and that's the part they never tell
us
mmm and then we'd like to think about
Armour 2.0 we talked about this when I
was little podcast last night yeah like
when we got to Armour 2.0 we were like
oh this is super exciting this is
awesome yes but then though there's a
catch yeah you had to have a certain
elemental affinity and the mother tied
to Sonoma and then you had you know this
like perfectly real armor and and then
the game was like working against you to
not give you good rules and they just
they do these weird things where it's
like why it's okay
it's okay if glad beats your strike in
five minutes yeah it's fine like that
ironically him beating it in five
minutes is watchable instead of me going
through it with three people in 40
minutes
that's not watchable because I'm sitting
in a corner trying not to die from the
overnight champion right because I'm
forced to use a really bad gun that's
not watch of sidearms my god yeah
machine guns for bear yeah you know
that's extremer is doing it solo in
under 10 minutes is way more interesting
which is it they don't like they don't
like the idea of us melting stuff is
obvious it's just such a people to be
able to do that to a point and again
this is one of the things that killed
division or division one early on they
tailored to the streamers it was the
crafting material that was like the a
lot of the streamers who'd played a lot
they had a whole lot of that materials
they were able to craft and work on
towards these god rules well then you
have like 95% of the population who
doesn't live in it like most of us who
are probably listening to this anyway
are more on the hardcore side as most of
the other
you know 500,000 people who might play
this game mm-hmm and then you have the
majority of them that are just like hey
I'm happy I got something and then
there's another person who blows away
there are speedruns from Mario 64
because people can backflip crap through
walls and stuff like that and that's
just like they have figured out the ways
to be the game and at some point you're
not gonna be able to nail down every
single thing of the point and they do
it's like they want to control that - a
very very weird level and it's just it's
like it's filled it with the control
that I really I really feel bad for the
speedrunning community in destiny
because it does anyone I I sort of
casually speedrun or speedrunnner Ike's
and and there was there was a fun aspect
to this but because the my effect the
modify isn't just anyone for the most
part they're so much better I don't know
man there's so many things that destiny
one that we still don't have in destiny
- and it's year for destiny - like but
that's a whole other yeah I would spew
drone strikes and destiny one and I
enjoyed it and and destiny - we would
occasionally do that like when were no
nothing came up the first time we got
the double drops we actually had three
actually we actually we had so much fun
speedrunning that like our first one was
30 minutes and then we got it down to 25
minutes enemy and then we kind of
changed her load and we got it sub 20
and then we're like alright could we do
sub 15 and you know we looked up we
looked up streamers or whoever
speedrunners and they were doing it like
12 or 13 minutes or maybe even sub 10 I
don't know whatever right and we weren't
aiming for that it was just like a
personal goal of like how fast can we do
this because I think of the day it's
about efficiency right like I get the
max amount of drops in the max amount of
time or the least amount of time and
there was something fun about that like
I had a really good time it wasn't even
the drops like yeah
having having you know ascendant shards
and all my characters postmasters and in
my inventory capped out that's great in
all and prisms too but at the end of the
day like there was I was having fun
doing challenging content it was
shocking like it's such a mind-boggling
concept yes and then they immediately
had to go and patch it well I guess it's
not technically patch I think it still
works
yeah but it just I don't like I feel
really bad when they nerve old-line
zero because it was such a small number
of players that were they were I'll use
the word exploiting because it is
technically a glitch but later it wasn't
doing like and from a speedrunning
standpoint from a community standpoint
destiny you can never go back to an
older version of destiny like you can't
uninstall the patch and boot right and
go see how I used so it's always you
always have to play in the moment which
basically means that all the speed runs
from that patch are just nothing like
they don't matter any they're just
cemented and yeah and that and that's
super unfortunate yeah again this is I'm
kind of going in tangent but like it he
goes back to that like control aspect of
the game like a and I almost feel like
they they're like the proctor on the
playground that's trying to keep all the
kids safe in the sandbox ultimately you
just got to let the kids out of the
sandbox it's like the kids are gonna
grow up it's fine
I'm very frustrated like if you can't
tell it's so it's so annoying when we're
entering your six of this game and it's
or your I guess your seven or seven and
come on like just that that's the only
reason why I worry recently that's the
only reason it is so again there's only
a certain amount of time but you know
people will continue to deal with things
they don't like that and again it seems
cyclical we understand it's a Live
service game thing there's gonna be
peaks is gonna be values I understand
that you know it's just you know I do
worry about them sometimes you know on
their own
ya know this you know we gotta talk
about it you know and and and seeing
them be able to recovering a and get
this thing right so you know again all
this is on them you know to take all
this feedback to implement it in a
correct way to able to respect time
investment to respect rewards for
Pinnacle content you know the onus is on
them because my biggest fear II
is now that we've kind of assuming that
there's not going to be d3 in the
immediate future
um yeah it's gonna be
you've got to wow people every time when
you come back I mean as I said like the
WoW expansions like you introduced like
vastly new things and systems right and
that's why was like the taking Kings and
the Forsaken 's not ended many systems
in the game built new things like they
questa fication terrible word but the
questa fication of Destiny in taking
King is what what everybody loved hey
these things have like six steps I gotta
go here here here there's a lot of crap
to do that's what people wanted forsaken
they got the random roles in there then
we got like two new destinations and
then we've got this forsaken subclasses
which would new introduction of like
nine more ways to play this game and
shadow key I love like this year's
narrative stuff in theory depending on
how the payoff is which I'm waiting for
has potential to be freaking amazing
potential like pyramid ships like in or
walk in on the shadow keep them like
holy crap that's the pyramid oh my god
going inside there having that happen
Garden of salvation talk to yourself
spoilers are anybody have that that's
fine yeah it's like that stuff's been
quite cool and I've enjoyed that but on
the other side like when you say raid
weapons haven't been that fun they've
been steering away from Pinnacle weapons
to rituals now we're going to pursuits
and all of those other things we're
steering away from what incentivizes us
to play the game and at some point this
isn't this isn't meant to be it the
story is cool but you got to have the
reason for me to play to experience the
story because I want to experience the
story but I want to have fun while I do
it
Danis Lucia's we're talking about on
swords I will honestly say I've used the
sword more this season than I ever have
now I know the change is screwed world
land 0 I get that for the speedrunning
community but also I can do 50% of
damage by myself with a certain build
and again when you talk about the mods
for the artifact like that one this
season both sword scavenger being
enhanced and then the one where like if
you equip a sword you take less damage
and it costs the energy that is a
perfect risk reward normally I will say
those things are expensive but if I'm
gonna run
heavy sword I gotta be up close in
general I should probably take less
damage if I'm in there and that's one of
those like that's one of the first times
I want that thing reissued because they
like button that makes you ya gonna be
like scavengers gone the perks so I can
survive more is gone the infinite
swinging animation helps for damage
because you can use them more especially
with like relentless strikes but again
if they take away the swords that have
written strikes and they sunset those
and they get rid of that then you have
your ammo coming up it again and
scavengers not it's just this like yeah
so I wanted to say that but I was like I
love how much I've used swords this
season it does suck it screwed the
speedrunning community but the
functionality of swords for me has
actually been more fun for the average
player so that's one of those to where I
understand the community being screwed
and that does kind of suck but the way
that works for the rest of the game has
actually been kind of cool so I get both
sides of the that one but I also wanted
to say it's like what they did the
swords for me was actually a lot of fun
so mmm look we've got we got to see how
this thing plays out in fairness you
know again I try to be fair with context
there's still stuff we still don't know
that should be introduced we could just
hope you know that there are our fears
and things that we're concerned about is
also paid attention to with the
introduction of these new things and
hopefully we could sit there and go oh
now I see why this tribe they did X Y &
Z because this was happening and this
way they just didn't they shouldn't
speak about smoke smoke on it but they
you know they just didn't at the time so
so they got man hopefully chat you guys
staying with us sorry but got anything
else for this I know we've like
belabored every point to them you got
anything else you want to add while
you're here I am optimistic to an extent
but they have it again they have this
track record of like there's always a
put and it's the monkeypod way yeah how
much mother yes where's the poop Robin
where's the poop yeah
that's a good show by the way um yeah
it's just there's always there's always
like a catch yeah that's what worries me
but mm-hmm I don't know I I was so upset
at first and then talking to my friends
and and other people about it I just
kind of was like you know what I'm just
gonna let them figure it out yeah and if
it's not fun it's not fun I'm still
gonna play the game I'll be vocal about
it respectful obviously you know a
people the people that are harassing the
devs online I get not sad human beings
okay yeah there are other games yeah
they are they are normal people just
like you and I don't do that that's like
really bad but it does vary in your game
it's a very and I think you could
benefit from like a game that would
bring competition because yes most part
destiny has been unchallenged in this
space they've knocked out all like
there's nothing in the space they know
everybody has bit the knee division was
supposed to be the Destiny killer right
and then you know they may had a bunch
of screw-ups anthem flopped I guess you
could say maybe warframe warfarin is
scratches that same age I bore the lands
to a certain extent kind of scratches
him but no game has really come close to
what doesn't he's achieved and I've
actually recently in losses ready I've
been I've been watching a bunch of the
GC talks where Bungie has talked about
different aspects of destiny over the
years and I also Halo Reach because it
goes far at that far back and I'm super
nerdy like that and I really like that
technical stuff and for me from this
place of like I got so frustrated with
the K and it was like all right I'm
technical I can understand this stuff
let me go watch a hour hour and a half
video of some Bungie dev explaining how
how zones work or in reach they
explained how they basically built the
networking infrastructure for that game
and how they figured out the big problem
of like packet latency and different
like communication problems it gets like
super technical and super in-depth
that's the kinda stuff I like I
understand the novel instead of that
just having someone explain it to me and
then even if it was a destiny one
thing or Halo Reach thing I could go
okay some version of this a better
version of this exists in destiny so I
can apply that logic to destiny okay
that's why this doesn't work the way it
should work or that's why it doesn't
function the way that we want it to
function or whatever right like there's
a bunch of explanations for tonight that
kind of helped me a little bit and gave
me a little more faith and there's just
but then all this stuff happened with
this season and that kind of just like a
big a big damper on it at that photo she
actually came from the trials issue yeah
I think is why I started looking this
stuff up but now just to close it off
like it's to see destiny goes through
these cycles it happens they're gonna
release a trailer in like a week or two
or something and we're gonna go be a
good idea always happens they make
really hype trailers and yeah I'm guilty
of it where I see it I'm like oh I can
do the last last song in the trailer for
season of the worthy I literally looked
up the band looked what it's from they
just have like epic music I'm like
listen well that randomly now it's like
so yeah it was good whatever they need
because they're worth it oh yeah
absolutely
that team can't get fired yeah so other
than that no that's you know but uh it's
been good there's been a lot of good
discussion so yeah well we can work on
wrapping this up chat you guys have been
amazing hang tight guys you want to raid
somebody on stream after this I'm gonna
send you guys over to send some love so
don't bail on us yet at least send some
love blow it up for them so but before
we do we're gonna wrap our side up so
Teddy where they can find you to get
your thoughts opinions and of course
your knowledge of the world of destiny
you'll have opinions out there where can
they find you sir
you can find me on twitter at teasing
Teddy it is T EAS ing t EDD Y all one
word I was streaming a little bit in
January and February and emic happen and
I got super busy so you can find me on
Twitter also a teasing teddy but I
probably probably not going to stream
very often especially with all the game
announcements coming up here works about
to kick up for me so we got to just at
the right time
yeah God you before you you can you can
always tweet at me on Twitter I'm
usually pretty good responding about
things just I ask you to respectful if
you're not I will belittle you in some
way because I've got a degree in logic
so like I'm not gonna remove all notion
from digital argument but yeah you know
you treated me you can message me I'm
always down to talk about destiny it's
by Twitter's mostly just destiny stuff
and like me making memes of tweeting
memes to people that I work with their
nose so yeah you know but thank you for
having me it's been another good podcast
so it's an interesting time for destiny
indeed yeah we've been through a few of
these kognito what else you got sir what
are you doing this weekend since we're
in the weekend now you know I love
podcasts on Sunday 1:00 p.m. Eastern oh
no guest this week just gonna be talking
about the latest stuff in the gaming
community all the stuff that's going on
ladies and Oh next generation hype and
SSDs and don't put speeds and IO in the
Sun you want to get I can't win so we
get more info on that stuff like oh yeah
so we get yeah I talk about that stuffs
do it again if you can't catch it on
YouTube we are also multi streaming so i
in my pocket has the same account here
on Twitch you can catch us stay alive
really appreciate the sport and of
course Lords of gaming that in that man
you guys have been amazing with that
support for the site we've been really
picking up and again if you're into
statues please check out my brother King
David King of statues man he's got an
amazing if you're into like Marvel
Comics DC Comics you know cartoon stuff
like he's got an amazing Tatara statue
from Thundercats and I'm going crazy so
check that out on the Isle of podcast
YouTube and yeah man and last thing I
want to say I know we talked that noisy
about destiny is just look I'm in this
place now where it's like I'm not gonna
complain if I'm not happy and I'm
literally killing my back I'm proud of
myself right now I'm killing my back
long so you know when they do something
good that I like I'm gonna jump right
back in and hopefully that'll be the
transition every piece going in you know
to the next season so that's what I got
on that but um email what's going on
with you man yeah I am like three
missions away from finishing neo I know
the final boss of all
those games is gonna be a brutal one so
stay tuned on twitch to me working on
that one I don't honestly know and I'm
probably enough to ask these two
afterwards if I can squeeze Final
Fantasy between buzz works picking up
for me I might have to just kind of
chill honestly like I'm gonna have to
chill wait for the new season in The
Last of Us
so that stuff will be coming but you
guys know we're here on Twitch even
catch this in audio form find all of
these awesome people find them on
Twitter find them on Twitch go find iron
Lords podcast they're live Sunday
mornings are amazing it's a great way to
spend a couple hours just chill leave
that little earbud in and you're good to
go but for me as well on YouTube do you
know like 2500 away from 50k on subs so
you guys have been awesome like that's
that's a big threshold that I can't wait
to get through so that's all I got
when we get done with the cascais we
were also gonna go rate a guy that I'm
gonna work on getting on the podcast his
name is amaze and if you've ever had
seen him like respond to a big raid he
will literally freestyle rap like for a
couple minutes so go follow him it's you
H it's weirdly spelled but it's uhm AAA
YYZ e so that's who we're gonna rate
after this one and just Teddy we're
gonna do the the last word sign-off here
again as well so for episode 104 may
22nd you guys have all been amazing
thank you chat Thank You teddy it has
been a pleasure having you kognito of
Costa co-host with Co most and thank you
very much we'll see you guys very soon
and it has been the last last word